all right if we are live welcome to the
last word episode number 83 and it's
another glorious Friday we're back in
front of the campfire with some more
looter shooter discussion I'm extremely
excited about our special guests so
we're gonna get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who both Eve artists
and I had the absolute pleasure of
meeting in the flesh at Guardian Con
2019 now on this Lord one of the most
dedicated destiny players in our
community but he has to triumph score
and the rate completion is to compute
introducing one of our most passionate
and hardcore members of Destiny
community and the guardian of Clan
concerned fellow warlock me fellow
friend of IG and Friday team chat and
the Lord of IT who rightfully plugs his
xbox controller into PC when booting up
destiny on Steam oh my god laughs from
Callie and cried enough to make his
debut within the realm of the last word
mom-in-law teasing teddy how you doing
sir dang I don't know I don't know I
don't to say it's like an amazing thank
you so much for having me this pleasure
to be here with you guys you guys are
awesome
control I know you can't see me but uh
controller master races it's it's God's
imprinted system I get so much flak for
saying that but it is it is it is the
superior way to play destiny talk about
so it's it's pretty pretty packed week
so I'm looking forward to this
absolutely I'm sorry I had changed it
right into it
no that'll just walk out the door you
guys are good
got your controllers
protocol I had to join with Denis - yeah
it's been a crazy week obviously we had
a little downtime as we were coming to
the end of the season but the info slow
shouldn't happened day after day after
day after day and now we're here to talk
about all of it with all of you so thank
you guys for tuning in this is obviously
we're live on twitch.tv slash
Montes right now so you guys are
listening on the audio yes can catch it
live watch us on our Twitter accounts -
no because sometimes the times will
change but we will get the audio up and
we can thank anchor for the audio for
the podcast you guys have been a great
host to us so take a second here and
thank them till you guys about anchor
and we will be right back so yeah thank
you guys anchor they've been a great
podcast host helped us get out there and
if you guys are catching us on audio
check us out on video as well always fun
to watch this live and all the
ridiculous faces that get to do what we
do in here so season of dawn gentlemen
are we ready to discuss slightly hived
out of your head good bad where we feel
just like 30,000 foot view where are we
feeling right now let's see where's mine
says peppery guess it's cautiously
optimistic that sounds like they oh yeah
they I mean sorry Cyrus didn't say 14
are by far both my favorite characters
Cyrus specifically as a warlock and
other stories are so intertwined and so
great and I want them to do well with it
but the story isn't enough to carry the
dlc the activity also matters and if the
activity is not rewarding and/or very
boring like flex offensive then i think
that kind of makes or breaks that you'll
see that being said though we have the
donning which is i think almost a month
long and crimson doubles which is a
little less popular so kind of see how
that flows into it but overall i'm
pretty pretty hyped but not super hyped
my expectations were met i guess is a
better way of like I kind of got what I
was expecting what you guys
kognito sir this is interesting for me
um obviously you know how much I love oh
sorry shadows you know warlock main as
well cuz my brother - yeah
so um you know from me cursor has always
left a bitter taste and you know you
just want it more from him so are we
gonna get right into the to the trailer
part now
where we going cuz you know I could go
but uh like you know give me overall for
the week how you feel no for the week
okay shut it down because I will tell go
crazy from setting that tee ball I'll
send it up there um listen I would say
at the start of the week Wow
you know I mean it's just wow and then
it's just hopeful as I went throughout
and con in a Teddy mode wants to stream
right let me temper expectations you
know once I found out certain
information
I got a tempered certain things I'm like
okay now we got a seat okay kind of way
I started off like super and then I kind
of like got into the teddy move well I'm
like all right we got it we got a seat
Oh a guy thinks oh where are you
II just a quick synopsis for you
emotionally mentally doing probably bit
on a similar rollercoaster I mean we'll
get into the trailer no question that
obviously but she knows how to hype
things up in 120 seconds but then when
we get to the streams and the activities
and numbers and information changes that
are coming
I mean it's destiny it's gonna be a
moving target always is and it's a
ten-dollar season if you compare it to
undying I think we're getting hopefully
a step in a good direction so I think
the cautious optimism is probably pretty
even across the board as we wrap up this
week so as we're gonna get our basic
30,000 foot views I'm gonna open the
door sorry Teddy I know you're the guest
but this one's for kognito because I
texted him because I saw the trailer
before him and I was like you're gonna
watch this and he's like what I was like
go watch the trailer and then there was
all capital letters in my text nothing
but caps just blew it up I was like dude
stop yelling but trailer launched not
too surprising on
what was it Tuesday right Tuesday
Tuesday the trailer launched and Cognito
thoughts about the trailer the god is
bad that is all right let me let me full
disclosure you know now I can get into
it the thing about it was obviously like
I said we curse the bitter taste you
know
I'm such a warlock being such a fanboy
at his character I think he's one of the
most coolest design characters and law
wise you already know how I feel so you
know obviously everything was leading to
it right I mean we looked at the tea
leaves we you know fix the timeline you
notice a season of dawn I mean it well
now we know it dawns related to him
that's actually not him at all right but
when we saw last week we did last word
and we should weep I mean not last week
looks weeks ago we did last time we did
last word we were talking about how
excited we were about to solder
sub-class changes right so we're like
okay and it just everything just seemed
to point to him you know to me and I'm
just like okay if this is not him this
is the greatest tease this is the
greatest you know head fake I've ever
seen so to see the cinema to see him
walk out and I was so ridiculous Teddy I
was tweeting um Oded Fehr who is the
voice actor oh I did this a week before
cuz I'm I know he had to come so to see
him it was great but to be brutally
honest as much as I'm a fan of Osiris
and warlock to see se for team come
behind it really took it to the next
level because again Osiris had a little
negative connotation with his DLC not
the character what is prior DLC so I
think Bungie did it amazing just the way
they set it up you see the paradox you
hear the Russian / Greek voice I'm still
trying to determine yeah I think it's
great it's Greek right okay I see the
conflict back and forth so I don't know
but whatever the voice is it's amazing
and the storyline just seems all right
like you said he bungee
knocked it out of the pot with the
trailer alone hype level through the
roof so that's where I was bitter when
you saw my text I was losing it I was
good crazy it's just a fantastic trailer
so where you guys that Teddy what's your
whole thing when you know you saw this
so the the Christmas iris trailer which
I think we can unanimously say that was
the worst expansion they've ever
released her do you see what everyone
call it not because of Osiris just there
was a lot of other factors dusting to
itself being an issue but the trailer
for Christmas iris that were he like
freezes time in the Vulcan flat
simulation that's like hands down and my
opinion the best thing they've ever put
out like easily because fog and and it's
forcing Osiris and the flesh and like
that was so cool and then the big
letdown that was that you'll see
unfortunately but this trailer has kind
of that's similar similar vibe to it and
I don't know it just
they got me I was like music was good
I'm a big fan of music and games and
movies and Destiny's always knocked out
of the park with music so I'm excited I
refuse eclis or his theme I really like
as well so I'm excited alright again
conscious optimistic like let me let me
let me get it on Tuesday
[Laughter]
you know I knew you're going to lose
your mind that was the easy part like
and it's like shadow to me what shot to
you for you your poker face like you're
so cool and calm about something I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna go crazy I was
like have you I just said have you seen
it or something like that was like and I
wanted you to go did cuz you could have
been asleep at the time it probably
should have been but yeah I was just
like you're gonna watch this whenever
you get to it but I was trying to stay
even keel for your song you're gonna
grow so what about you like you for
seeing everything where was your head
emotionally I can watch that trailer
over and over just because I want to
shout out like it's one of those things
where it's like if you've ever done any
editing of video you appreciate what is
done more and more and more like the
more you watch TV shows the more you
watch movies and just the way like the
frame jumps with like every drumbeat
when they're looking through the
different versions I am and like all the
little pieces of the trailer I'm just
sitting there's like two two two and
it's like the drum beats and it's going
through time and then you have like the
giant saint-14 bubble is he's holding it
out I mean for me just as a Titan mean
it's like saint-14 coming out was just
about as big it's like Osiris I'd seen
and it's like it was awesome to see him
come back because he does need some he
needs to get a second chance because not
his fault but DLC not the best time for
him he knows a chance to try and make it
a little better and at a better time
like he's like you know I I didn't get
to save my friend previously and that's
what he wants to do and then you see you
see the floating shotgun you see him
grab it you see the hand come out and
then just like the 14 you're like so no
I loved it but honestly for me I mean i
sat there and broke down I have like my
videos I know they're too long and I
honestly didn't say this week because I
was breaking it down frame by frame I'd
be like alright pause let's look here I
have 29 minute video about a two minute
trailer so the hero we need but not the
hero we deserve I don't know whatever
the phrase is Emma but here we need but
not a lot of people watch it because
it's too damn long but I don't care but
we got to see potentially like what's
going on with the story having all
pieces of mercury broken but at the same
time then we figure out later the
sundial is that and I think normal
mercury is gonna look like mercury but
just like I love the different ways that
mercury looked through time that was
always a really cool thing and we got
such a tiny glimpse of that in the story
when you get to see past you see it in
the strike all the time but there's not
a lot that deals with the future the
dark really dark kind of future future
of X and very dark version of mercury
and we actually get to see that kind of
potentially in every
the sector every time we play so seeing
all the different pieces of mercury and
then we have three timelines that we
know about but this fourth broken
shattered timeline of monochromatic
broken glasses I'm really curious as
that just story related are we gonna
have maybe a boss fight in there I'm
very curious what that's all about so
trailer itself
yeah all triped of course cuz I mean you
can't take two minutes of a bunch of
trailer not be like hell yeah if unless
you're just like not a fan so know for
me the trailer was crazy I want to ask
both of you um again I'm trying it's
hard to keep emotions out of it but my
question again with just trailer
rankings we're gonna get into that you
know deep dive and in the stream but
where do you guys rent this all time if
you have to think about all the trailers
I'll just think about other trailers
that got you as hype for an expansion
that destiny has done you know where
would you guys place this taking king
has to be on the top two for me mm-hmm I
think taken King would probably the top
one just because that opening you had
seen is like it's just so good but I
probably put this as like top three yeah
it's good like it's so you gotta take
the king what else you got Teddy just if
you're the Osiris one trailer wise what
about you eat the same kind of cadence
well I mean taking King definitely up
there just for them the gravity of his
power and you see Oryx is actual power
of his ship when what he does is still
always one of the biggest trying to
think of some of the other ones that
we've had for other cinematics and
things I'm trying to remember it was
cool rise of iron was actually cool with
Saladin and like the sea bow and
shutting that thing down yeah so I mean
those are definitely pretty cool but I
think this one showed a lot of potential
in the trailer because I think actually
I liked and also some of one iconic
character we have not seen and bringing
one back that needed it so I think the
characters involved gave it as much
weight as many others cuz I mean have
Saladin's cool but we see him like you
know every three weeks or every other
week it feels like lately but we see him
a lot so his trailer was cool and
nice to see an old story but this is
like now it's like in you know in the
actual more at this point and both are
huge massive character so it definitely
had some weight in there for me with
that so it's up there for sure yeah I'm
just saying I'm gonna say in pocket yeah
definitely taking king you definitely
remember how epic you know he Oryx was
as a villain and how true the threat was
and the new enemy type and all that
stuff would have taken but um yeah man
this just the the iconic level of both
Osiris and say 14 we know the payoffs to
the story we know and what was dealt was
the way it was cut with the same 14
mission with the you know the VEX
memorial made added a lot of you know
flavor to it so for me again just
trailer you know that I have to put it
up there probably the fighting with one
or two I would say probably two but this
is there so yeah my fish by taken King
this and in curse because I was you know
the first time I have a source at her so
yeah I was like that ones up there for
you yeah I got my Cyrus bought the glass
by ugly my favorite gray it's like it
was just so much good or it was like it
was also the idea of like it's the
implications of what's happening when it
says when you slow which I'm not sure
always I keep hearing that warden like
is that Grammer right but I know they
would have checked it a hundred times
it just sounds weird and but when he's
like when you slew the undying mind it's
like the implications of you see the
wave of energy from the traveler
basically stop and they're trying to
actually go back and change time and I'm
sitting there going okay some people are
gonna be mad because they're working
with time travel everybody gets always
angry about that but to if this is a
point and even I think Luke or someone
said this is not like the best
connection that we wanted even story
from season to season but this is like
really a good place for us to start and
I think that could be potentially them
not completely like wiping out
everything we've done but also giving
them a place if they truly want to build
the narrative momentum going into Season
nine ten eleven year four or five six
all that stuff this is a point for them
or like okay we need someplace to build
from this is where we start and I think
that's actually pretty cool
almost had some in-game Avengers you
know
affinity for in-game kind of vibes to it
with the multiple timeline y'all see the
Cabal now trying to change the effects
with the red war so I thought that was a
little homage a little touch to that you
didn't say have to fix the timeline what
we did affected that now whether or not
um I like the transition in the game is
another story you know say the kraler
was amazing and I spoke shot the Attic
part of my only issue was again we know
how Luke had made the whole point about
seasons transitioning into you should
have been there moment we all agreed
that diamond mine was it was not the
greatest transition in a saying so we
were it exactly so we were expecting you
know something I put it this way I wish
we would have so in a perfect world just
the Osiris part talking to us
in-game and I go to mercury right yeah
oh yeah that's I guess I totally agree
you know you know what I'm saying it's
like it's just so close cuz again the
trailer now gives everything up but I do
you just need that in-game transition to
set it up to that's the only I you know
misstep I would say happened here but um
you know I don't know where you guys are
at with that transition we didn't have
you said I mean it's the the real world
transition is awesome but the in-game
transition is kind of lacking but again
I once the undying mine came out and we
got what we got and it wasn't this like
reprisal of the boss or the strike or
anything we were and that's when I was
kind of like all right you know if this
is what they're gonna do I'm gonna
temper my expectations and so again I
kind of got what I expected I wasn't I
wasn't - it wasn't like too upset or too
disappointed anyway but it's but Bungie
bungees hurt my heart I'm getting old
we agreed he had a choice choice words
and feelings like last last word you
know regarding that you know it's just
I've gotten I've gotten too upset too
many times at them because I love the
game I mean that's that's the real
reason but yeah we all do and and and I
rather than getting upset at them I've
come to this place and last I would say
to a lot since you came back I think
that was a big turning point I've tried
to more understand their line of
thinking and their reasoning and not
necessarily to justify it but just so
that for myself and so I can communicate
it to others to try to understand like
why did they do this why did they do
like this why did this happen and you
know making games is complicated like
it's not a it's not an easy thing and
I'm sure they have their own constraints
and at the end of it a they are business
they got to make money and that's what
fuels their decisions and whether we
like that or not you know we can voice
our concerns but if they in chat saying
this is also the moment when you realize
when we saw in the Vedic back in June or
whenever it was when you see the
whiteboard and it says fix the timeline
we're like that's real yeah this is
actually like this has implications that
like a little whiteboard of those like
years of planning it's like they do have
a hope of something that they want to do
so it's like really really cool I think
they've got enough crap probably
everywhere I don't think enough people
who are like is this it like the way
they hide it like I got an email from
Bungie regarding the entire mine and
logging in and you know again so I'm not
trying to go too hard on them but the
expectation was there like if
something's burnin isn't happen yeah
himself so it was on the road no it was
on the road map like that was the thing
that we were expecting we should have
learned from mark week with the road map
but still
I'm holding feets to fire all the
terrible chairs I'm sorry I under
respectfully I understand what you're
saying and we know they're independent
and with all the resources alone I'm
trying to be as respectful as possible
again it's just we talked about it at
Guardian con with a couple of the the
Bungie guys and the thing about this
game the reason why I was so I'm gonna
say Petiot ridiculous is just that you
know this game has some of the most
iconic lore buried behind it even when
you want to do a raid and one thing I
spoke to one of the members of the r18 I
was just like there's something to be
said when you start up last wish and you
hear petra venj voice right and she's a
deplaning what's about to happen just
those little nuances add so much if you
just give a cinematic you know the
oldrin thing these little things you
don't saying that and again it may be
harder to create then I even know but or
all I'm saying is that that really adds
to world building and character building
and I just wish like I said if they
undermine with just what it was okay
fine
but if we would have had this Osiris
last a14 development in the game told us
in a nice transitionary way I would have
been money up broad I leave him alone I
understand I agree like if if a sire
showed up you know like this week since
this is last week and he's like hey what
you're doing with the undying mine is
causing these problems and it literally
just like one line of dialogue what a
motivate a difference not a percent well
I I agree like but I thinking about it
now since we're just talking about it I
kinda also give them a pass because this
was the shadow keep season so kind of
what a bond test was saying that I think
this is their stepping off point right
to continue that world building and also
obviously feedback right like you know
we're saying this is not good and
hopefully the the next seasonal
transition and the following seasonal
transition is a little bit better since
I would imagine the seasons probably
have like a six month development time
yeah it would be my my guess my rough
estimate they did also mention seasons
were kind of developed in in a
combination matter right we're so yeah
yeah this was already kind of done in
conjunction with a shadow king season
one dying
correct yeah they they may come in
parallel there they work on them
simultaneously yeah I mean they have to
commit to choices long enough in
abeyance and development to be like yeah
we have to make this it's like okay we
can learn lessons from stuff like nine
months ago but we can't learn lessons
from this transition yet I mean but it
was like also Prescott
it was WD is saying like Luke
unfortunately painted that amazing
picture of 8:01 walking in and walking
out and all the stuff with the drifter
and he's like hey come come visit me
when she leaves or something like that
in your mind it's like that's what we
want and he said in theory that's what
we would love to have but it's like can
you tell us when that might be happening
because if it's like here down the road
I'm gonna pull my expectations right
back cause right now you put them up
here and then you chop my knees off so
it's just like it's just kind of those
couple of things that's like they had
set as you said between the calendar
between his description of that and then
just like hyping it up and then you
finally if you were to like get your
email and then you log in at home and
you're like it's the same on level one
same on level two there's no voice
difference and he comes to the okay it's
just like and that's like that's kind of
a letdown
but we at least have this trailer but I
think as you said Cognito it almost
could have been better if you know you
log in on Tuesday and there's like you
just hear a voice over just in orbit
saying and it's just like Osiris talking
to you somehow say be like hey what you
did with the undying mind it kind of
broke things come see me on Mercury you
fly in and then you see that cinematic I
know they're doing the cinematic for
sales people get hyped yeah I've put
also in turn like I kind of wish they
didn't because that would be almost a
better transition that would be cool so
yeah so that we've definitely looked at
the trailer a lot of it I've broken it
down a lot we'll cover more pieces as we
go but the second thing we got on a
Wednesday the stream so who watched this
thing live who caught it later would you
guys think did you guys enjoy how how
would you rank the stream was it good
would you guys think whoever wants to
get it going skits get in you I I think
it was one of their weaker streams but
that being said I don't think it was
like bad
I think it was more weak simply because
they didn't show as much as they
normally do which anecdotally from
experience that's usually not a good
thing when they're kind of coy with
information this close to release at
least but I don't know right like you
know we didn't really see enough of the
Sun now for me to make like a full
assessment of it just enough of it that
I was like all right I'm interested now
you know if it's like menagerie then I
guess he'll be ok but it was it was kind
of math like if I had to rank it I'd
probably say it's like a 7 out of 10
because wasn't bad wasn't great I think
Teddy nailed it for me you know
obviously you know the the aesthetic you
started to see the the same 14 kind of
armor sets and stuff like that I thought
that was cool I thought sundial looked
cool like I had a potential I mean
anything that's menagerie asked at this
point I'm gonna be a fanboy of I love
that activity I think it's one of the
greatest activities going on it was cool
to seed curse of Osiris weapons you know
come back I thought I thought that was
really cool you know um you know
obviously as a warlock mean I wanted to
see a lot of these sub their solar
subclass stuff in action so getting to
see the little three fireballs girl that
looks so cool I was like okay so I
started off hi I was actually really
cool that you know we got some artifact
breakdown I'm starting to understand the
logic behind where they're going with
that as far as um well it almost feels a
like um like like induced meta changes
where it's like hey oh yeah try these
things out because these mods are gonna
be here and I actually don't mind it
because I think as designee players we
kind of get locked into our loadouts and
we get locked into comfort you know
there is an Aggie recluse Swami Raven
loaded night COO is probably the prime
example you know yes so that's that I
mean as far as now this is where I'm
totally in agreement with teddy is that
you know after the Sun Dial thing
they showed me their couple of things
they showed me one or two other things
but it ended so abruptly yeah yeah like
I felt like they I was I was in pocket I
felt like I was I was gonna get like
another 20 more minutes or so and it was
just like okay boom and into Teddy's
point I've never seen them so secretive
so non revealing you know we'll talk
about pinnacles and all that you know
later about you know they'll be there
but you know it just felt like hmm and
then let's be real the elephant in the
room at least for me it was trials of
Osiris right so coming in I before this
I kept expectations low trials was on
hiatus they've told us a million times
blah blah blah okay fine now you know
we're getting your cyrus tidbits the
bread comes you see the trailer you like
hmm maybe then you see in the trailer
3v3 elimination map hmm maybe right it
is like then you hear you know through
the scuttlebutt shout out to rent it and
everything real crafty and these guys
the hardcore trials guys going to Bungie
may be right you know as a child fan I'm
sitting as a pvp guy I'm sitting there
like yo this might happen so now I'm
getting in now right before the stream
shot to fall out and I believe Miss
5,000 watts and they brought me right
back down there and they were like find
out later they like this right now
now and I'm like oh cuz I'm thinking
they were gonna show sundown but they're
gonna have like a peek like a classic
Bungie PvP guys you know set up with all
the classic so I'm like okay so they're
not there okay that means if they come
in here that means Charles ain't this
season so I really shot myself back down
but even shot him myself back down to no
trials I have to agree with Teddy again
I just felt so abrupt in and like they
just weren't going to reveal a lot and
that could go two ways right I can go
like hey Lee got much to show so we're
gonna stretch this out or you know it
can be like they it's really
didn't we just want to try a new
approach so I'm gonna give it to you
yeah I've been rambling you know I
didn't get a chance you still stream I
don't think we talk much post dream and
I gotta know where your head's at with
this dream well first thing we got it is
nice and as somebody I forget who said
it in chats just there the I was agent
grizzly the excitement the Bungie
developers have the writers have for the
story working with these characters I
got yeah I was like when they started
out talking about it like the hype that
those two I think the first two on the
chairs had yeah that was cool like
because we get to see this world that
they've built and these developers are
just like ultra pumped about it and it's
nice to know that hey we're excited
about seeing Osiris in saint-14 and
they're sitting in the same boat they
just get to make it so they're having a
really good time on that front so that
was actually cool and like okay so we're
talking about the Lord we haven't seen
any game play it cool mm-hmm then Tomo
comes out and then I forget who he was
sitting next to but they went through a
little bit more of the hunter and they
were showing we got to see the character
we're looking at 960 power and I'm going
yes what does that mean is it none is it
a little bit what are we doing but we
didn't get any answer on that so we'll
trust me when it end it was like and
then finally I saw him like Twitter that
it was gonna come tomorrow because I
work tomorrow I worked the next night I
was like I've gotta wait till the end
just to see it so that was like kind of
that that part but then we got to dig
into artifact which after breaking it
down we got to say they're going in a
more range so we did get to see that
we've got Scouts pulses snipers linear
fusions Bo's kind of all ranged
precision hits yeah or all of the mods
for unstoppable for barrier autos are
gonna be your overload I'm broke most of
it doesn't look like they've like
ventured far though because if you break
down the other couple of columns the
ones they didn't go too deep into did
they did the new one with the healing
orbs so healing orbs for yourself from
precision hits I'm like that seems odd
because you have to precision shoot
something from far away but then you get
a orb that sits way out there that you
have to go yeah I'm like okay it's kind
of weird but what to see how that one
plays out in real
but then you get to see it's like the
variations aren't that much different
you've got breach refractor that was
just grenada energy now it's grenade and
and mainly energy but it's a little
costlier instead of Arc battery it looks
like it's a void battery and they main
they may be placeholders but this far
along I'm guessing it's probably pretty
close so it doesn't look like they're
really changing the game I mean the
heavy finisher which I don't think I
ever heard anybody hardly use yeah
because it's just too costly and unless
that things just a little tweaked it
still doesn't seem like it's worth it
and they haven't even like put anything
else in there so for me the artifact was
like hey what are gonna be the new mods
are we gonna play any different more
builds and play styles and honestly
looks just gonna be like a solar
variation on a couple of things but
voids still in there so it's not really
a big departure which was kind of that
feel I like the I like the theory behind
it but like for them to say hey we can
put game-breaking things in there for
three months and then you know we know
what's going away it's temporary it
doesn't seem like they step too far away
from like their little comfort zone it
doesn't feel like they've ventured very
far with creative mods at least from
what I could see and then the other
thing we got to see the new mods now
that has me intrigued the new armor mods
yes so we've got the new mods with
regards to getting eight like getting
charged with light and then consuming
the light for these different abilities
couple of them sound fairly cool some of
them we're gonna cost you stats which is
an interesting trade-off like to use one
of them it's gonna cost you - to
discipline there's no one there so
they're definitely getting deeper into
the builds on that side which I am
intrigued about because armor for me I
was getting to be more fun is definitely
something I'm looking forward to I still
have issues with armor 2.0 but that's
something and then we get to the sundial
a mic cool so we got the opening section
I'm like waiting to see these different
zones okay we're going into the future
mercury and then BAM it's cut off and I
was like I'm sorry what I was in the
same boat like like for both you guys it
was just like how does it go from here's
the build here's the armor and as you're
seeing like 37 minutes into the stream
and it just like dies I don't know how
they could go back hard to just by it's
that's that's a dress
that was either a producer or somebody
who wrote the program for that like
stream was like I don't know what to put
at the end of this just cut it obviously
I'd like to recycle the trailer
it's so weird there could have been some
other recap at the end like hey we do
and I think I heard this like I did
listen to shout out to DCP I just
listened to him today it was like
working on the house and for even then
it was just like hey this could be a
time even just for deej to say it's like
some of you may have questions about
power level we're gonna have some
details tomorrow
some of you may want to see the ritual
weapons we honestly want to surprise you
with those these things will exist but
at this point we're trying to keep
things a little bit more of a mystery as
we go into this next season so you guys
can experience it because we have had
some feedback saying that maybe you've
told us too much upfront they didn't
show us exotics so there's no teasers
about those no exotic armor so I mean
where do we get the gun though it was a
gun there's like there's a couple yeah
there's a couple gun trailer they
haven't shown the armor like we gotta
see the veil on the hunter before and
stuff so correct they're being a little
more kay to you some stuff and honestly
just occasionally if you were just like
we want you guys to enjoy some of the
surprises so let us know your feedback
but honestly at this point and that may
be almost too candid for deej to say but
something along those lines in deep
speak would have been kind of I think a
better way to end it than just and
that's all we got and we'll see you
later like just a J Palmer transition
out of it to say we do have more to show
you there's more for you to see once you
log in on Tuesday it just felt a little
odd I think on the end I'm a listener so
I have been trying it but I've got some
thoughts on the the mods and the
artifact so the the new mods ignore the
artifact for a second but the charge
with light mods from what we saw we
didn't see a lot of them but from what
we saw on paper they seemed very
interesting and very usable but we'll
have to see the effects if they're worth
it but that leads me to another problem
that you kind of touched on which is
armor 2.0 so when they when they
advertised armor 2.0 to us they
basically told us and this was in Luke's
developer commentary this isn't their
fight ox leading up shadow he they were
they were like played the game the way
you want to play the game now if you
compare if you compare destiny before
shadow Keith mmm you could pretty much
put any set armor on and it worked like
what a perks aside like you needed good
rolls but if Ekta flee you could put any
piece armor on it and we're fine but now
with armor 2.0 you're fighting so many
levels of RNG to get a not not a god to
piece of armor a usable piece of armor
and I'm pigeon-holed into all I have to
get this element I have to get this I
have to get this and then I'll and then
all of a sudden this new season comes
out and it's like okay we got these new
awesome mods and unlike last season they
work everywhere but all that armor you
grind it forward that it's like kind of
okay or maybe got tier it's kind of
useless now because the mods don't like
work on that yeah and I get it they want
us to keep playing the game and that's
you know that is part of their I'm sure
symmetric or goal that they have
whatever but that I think really put a
sour taste in my mouth when they were
like yeah you have to get the new armor
again I'm regardless I'm gonna grind the
armor but that's beside the point
mmm and then you have the artifact which
I'm really torn about the artifact
because I on the one hand I really like
the idea of this thing that you level up
every season and the power goes away but
on the other hand I also don't like that
Triumph's news is I have to get to rank
20 every season and if that you know
those three months I'm busy an hour have
the time to grind bounties endlessly
that you know that that affects me
negatively 20 mm-hmm so if you get 22
get the max triumph the tier 3 of that
triumph which goes away at every season
because the triumph specifically for
whatever artifact that season is tied to
and then the mods and the artifact they
the way they advertised that to us was
these are mods that we'll put in the
game that are kind of experimental which
that's true they did put in some pretty
experimental mods
and then the specific line that I'm that
I'm referring to is at the end of the
season we'll look at what mods worked
and which ones didn't and we'll put some
of them in the game as permanent mods
yes there was no mention of that at any
point now I'm not saying that what is
the grenade buff one and the Ark one
should be the game of darts
Thunder cool I'm not saying there should
be in the game I think those dozen to be
out of the game but there are some other
ones on there that I think would
permanently be good additions to the
game mm-hmm
but they haven't said anything so I'm
kind of like are you just scrapping that
idea altogether is this just a you know
I wanted done thing and then lastly you
touched on the weapon part I I kind of
like when they're like hey you know
these are the weapons for this season
we're trying to kind of induce this this
meta meta if you will by forcing players
seize these weapons but I also don't
like that because if the weapons end up
being like pretty bad archetypes or
weapons that just need some love it
really limits what you can do especially
the PvP sandbox right like if if the
auto rifle is the focus I'm not gonna
put her on a rifle on a pvp let's be
honest like but if we need to for
whatever reason for something a triumph
or a bound or whatever it just it it
makes the game less enjoyable and then
we kind of talked about this before the
stream but my effort to progress in
something actively makes me a detriment
to my teammates in the NVE
because I have to have this bad loadout
on which is it's a whole other rant that
I could get into and I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna go down that road but that
that also kind of bothers me but I'm
again I'm kind of cautiously optimistic
because I might be worried but then
nothing nothing might come of it right
like it won't it won't matter I'm only
gonna put it on for the knife fall or
something which the power is going up
that might also not be a problem anymore
I was like I need to literally make that
list into bullet point so let's start
breaking them down so easily I was like
so we started like armor 2.0 for me is
an issue like because I'm with you
you have the RNG of I finally got a
legendary piece of iron banner
to drop it like 60 points and it was
actually usable and I was like thank god
that's like one of my first ones this
season wow this actually was like not
trash that's when I get 20 plus mobility
I'm like I can't use this like I got I
got like a 65 or 67 piece armor and
reckoning the other day and I think 20
plus of it was a mobility another time
this wasn't strength and I'm like I
can't really anyway sorry I finally get
one piece and that is season 8 iron
banner armor which will not use these
new mods so I'm like throw that out like
I'm just gonna go on okay so as you're
like major issues I've got with like the
mods armor 2.0 is like exotic armor in
fear like honestly the idea of kind of
by exotics already you have to try and
get a roll of good stats anyway then you
have to try and get an exotic to drop
that you want why does he even have an
affinity on it in the first place can it
just be like rainbow affinity or
whatever you want to call it like haha I
don't know the proper term but like use
like our RGB or whatever but like
exotics if you want to go full
especially like if you're going for like
nightmare hunts or anything like that
the give-and-take thereof why do I want
to do a little less here for a little
more there let me use the exotics and
like have just the exotics go throw that
extra slot out there and be like that
you don't Asterix just like seasonal
slot exotics just work because it's hard
enough to go for hey I finally got a
crown a tempest it stats blow nevermind
and then I may get another one later on
that I might use mmm sounds like I just
like to see Armour get that and then you
talk about the seasonal mods of like
okay I just got that sixty stat but it's
not gonna work with the new mods with
this charge with light which sounds like
it has potential because there's one
higher the charges you get I don't know
what did cryptic say I'll get to that in
a second yeah a few moves you can
slightly write your mic will look like
state for it to you hear this
[Laughter]
so you knew YouTube's algorithm just got
marks not for kids by the way
[Laughter]
anyway I can't I can't see it now but
yeah it's like you also have things like
they haven't mentioned the giant pain
that is exotic weapons that can't use
mods period so you have things like
suros for overload rounds you've got
graviton Lance which I wouldn't mind
using cuz pulses are coming but I can't
go slap anti barriers on it to hate it
from far so all of those things not
touched and those are all quality
lighting the faded Engram change it's
like it's not amazing but it kind of
band-aids the problem yeah I'm torn
because with the exotic part I see what
first why I agree with both do you in
reference to exotic affinity I think
that's for the affinity in itself we I
feel at this stage we should have some
kind of resolution in terms of we know
there's this extra layer of our orangey
so why don't we have a resource maybe
even shards or prisms to change said
affinity to work with a build you want
so at least you have that flexibility
right so that's one two this is the part
I'm torn with far as artifact mods in
pertaining to the specific season and
exotics there's part of me that loves
the fact that they are limited to
legendary and that we get a chance to
mess with the meta
and um in the sense that okay because
the part is about the process there's
part of me that says yo I'm gonna get to
try different guns just try different
and yes it is for us it is it is mess in
Teddy's point it is constraining you to
a specific way of playing that may not
be helpful to your teammate sometimes
you don't say I will agree with that
however there's another part of me that
says well if it we do open it up to
exotics you know how crazy could it get
like I mean you know I mean I'm torn man
cuz parties like that's all but a BTE
though it's like that's not gonna hurt
like you're telling me if you go run
through a knife hall strike and you're
like oh maybe I want to go through anti
berry on my risk runner just right run a
little different than you want to I mean
again you're looking it like the whole
idea of recluse being this overwhelming
force and yeah they're gonna try and
push him away from that with more ranged
focus but then in turn if I have to go
throw anti barrier monzón enough say
we're running a nightfall and I'm not
gonna go depend on the other two whoever
I'm gonna get paired up with I'm gonna
need some type of auto rifles say it's
overload and I'm run in that type of
strike and then they need anti barrier
unstoppable I'm not and I can't use
that's two slots mm-hmm can't use an
exotic eating either one mm-hmm
and that's where there's quite a few
options the guns again older ones like
sweet business like graviton lance light
suros regime good could give you a lot
of variety and again these are guns that
we've been holding on to for a while
that I just thought will have a reason
to use no you're right you're not wrong
I think where I struggle I'm kind of
playing the company line now is that
Shelton
I know let me let me show for bungie
never give a [ __ ] oh oh well I do worry
for balance with them because again if
we got the sweet business it like
forgive scouts are running around like
if we got Polaris Lance running around
with you know unstoppable and stuff like
that I do worry how strong that is like
how how really powerful is in
conjunction with the other intrinsic
exotic perks so from balance standpoint
maybe they saying to themselves we don't
want to open it up just like that
because we can't control they could
start melting stuff you know I'm saying
because we all know since you know
season and drift away directly and all
that stuff and all the nerves weak
you know to a lot of exotic armors and
skull dynamic are and stuff like that
they're on this thing where they don't
want us melting things they don't want
us just tearing through content and I
think part of me does side with them a
little bit from a player standpoint it's
fun right you get your bill you throw on
your your huckleberry throw your wrist
for them SMGs are the season to do
whatever and you can have okay go jump
it gates now I just have a counterpoint
to this because I go for it
the only function of these mods is to
literally break shields stop and
unstoppable in their track and overload
the same principle to stop them from
moving if the guns in of themselves are
balanced that shouldn't be a factor at
all
so really what you're trying to do is
just tell me it's like we don't want you
using exotics in your PvE loadouts
because if they feel like those guns are
balanced didn't they do these sandbox
sweeps and they'll know them again if
graviton lanes got a 30% buff but I
can't go use it when pulse rifles are
going on My Mind's going what the hell
yeah listen from a player's standpoint I
feel it's more fun that way and it's
definitely you know something that it
would make me use I will say this to
your defense like let's say this was the
sidearm please cuz we please jump in
today but say is this like in AI seeing
your point with let's say for example
ass I know I'm seasoned right and you
know sidearms had today it would be cool
to dust off racking right if Polaris
Lance's in the game as is if you can use
it anyway all I'm gonna do what that
thing is just break some champion
mechanics and then I'm still gonna have
the same gun that's all it does and they
honestly like I was kind of curious if
we were gonna get something besides
overload barrier and unstoppable mm-hmm
those are still identical
they're just on different enemies we've
now got cabal and the sundial and things
like that but I've got a couple of
things sort of the infinity since that's
the count we're at so you know I think
affinities gotta go
just like flat-out I think it's gotta go
at first when they announced it I was I
was a little upset about it and people
were kind of like digging into it and
they were like okay which mods work on
what and then and then it came out we
get we got our hands with it and we were
like okay you know I can kind of see
what they were going for but then they
put out this Bungie update when they
attempted to justify the affinity system
and that's what I was like and that's
when I was like this is the dumbest
reason in the world so they basically
said that the reason that you cannot
equipped mods to any mod any affinity is
then the menu was too confusing there
were too many things in the venue and I
immediately immediately loaded up my
inventory with 50 shaders inspect that
an item hit down on the d-pad because I
planned controller OPM control
masterrace opened up the the shader
minion was like look I've got 50 shaders
right here you think this is too
confusing for me this is the same menu
that the mods used there's something
different in this menu like the 6x a
menu what is what about this is
confusing when it for the mods like I
just don't understand the reasoning so
when they said that I was like alright
this is just one of those Bungie things
where their philosophies kind of set and
they're not gonna change it and the only
way that I can understand is if I sit
down with one of them and talk to them
and be like all right give me your
reasoning like why why do you think this
is right and you know am I having a
guardian Connor or they're other things
[Music]
that's that's one of my big my big
gripes is that that's got to go like I
especially because they they flat out
were like we want to give the player
this wanna get in the way they want to
play
but that's somewhat ironically there's
been a couple reddit posts about this
the past couple days or it's like you
don't actually have choice it's kind of
this weird illusion of choice where you
think you have a choice but you don't
have a choice
you've been limited more and in this
weird way and so this is kind of this is
a huge tangent so destiny I personally
call this the Fanus effect so this is
gonna take some explaining so when when
you have something when something in
destiny is super powerful let's say
mountaintop recluse swimmer the raven
that met it right and we were we were
just melting things we were destroying
things mm-hmm our expectation and our
mindset for how something should be
murdered and destiny is now xspeed right
like it's this boss dies this fast
because I have this loadout with my
teammates I love it so because I know
how fast that thing is supposed to die
and I've you know I've killed whatever
boss X amount of times Y amount of times
and then they go hey all these things
aren't stacking all these d buffs and
buffs are stacking we're nerfing you
know Auto reloading which I'll give them
that one that needed to go but you know
all these things are changing and all of
a sudden I've become this little like
school kid on the yard who's trying to
like beat up the big 6th grader and it's
like well I can you know I'm looking
like baby Yoda here kind of looking up
in the wrong like it's it's not it's
just it doesn't make sense right and the
reason I call the Thanos effect is
because you can't unknown you can't and
if you're a new player like you'll never
get to experience that so that's not an
issue but as for us as veteran players
and I think both of you have played
Justin you want since the beginning it's
it's kind of weird where you go through
these phases of like we know how one
thing is supposed to work and then they
change it because you know we're monster
killing machines to use their verbage
and they don't like that right we're
killing things and some sometimes I
agree with them like recluse mountaintop
that was too good they had to go but
then sometimes too I'm like is it really
that bad if i murder the thing that fast
right like does it does it really matter
like who does this negatively impact if
I if I kill the boss before he does his
mechanic yeah she'll respond to you when
you finished it but but there's one
other one other point I wanted to make I
think it was what did you say after the
affinity I'm sorry I blanked here we're
talking exotics it's far as um mods
being able to yeah placed on them as
well oh I play devil's advocate I I
think that they they won't you can't
touch on this I don't think they will
add the mods the seasonal lots of the
exotics for fear of something getting
broken but here's my devil's advocate
point let's go Destiny's PvE is at its
best when things are broken hot take hey
and and when I say broken I don't mean
like something is not functioning
correctly I mean like we are mountaintop
recluse Inge everything to death like
that is that is when PvE is at its best
right because we are you're building a
monster killing machine right it's it's
there's this little-known game called
Diablo 3 I don't know it's made by an
indie studio yeah they did a lot of they
did a lot of things for anything and
they did a lot of things wrong and you
can't you kind of touched on this with
the reroll of the affinity extras is
what I wanted to get to so so Diablo
Diablo didn't get a lot of things right
at the beginning just like this in fact
they have a very similar parallel story
and it's been known that Blizzard did
help Bungie during the early days of
just to kind of kind of kind of get them
back on track right
aaaah blow there are so many different
systems and mechanics that allow you to
reroll something whether it's a stat or
inability or whatever right and and I'm
not saying they got it right the first
time on everything you know it took them
a long time to get where do they are but
destiny is much simpler than Diablo and
I don't see why there shouldn't be like
a glass needles type thing or or some
mechanic right where it's like well it's
like hey I got this you know kind of
tempest that dropped for me but it's
it's not the affinity I want let me just
pay some costs and let me roll it right
or have a range of energy I'm exotic so
what doesn't it's just it just it seems
such a bizarre
design choice and I I don't understand
that's what I want to talk to them and
like try and understand it but you had
it you had a counterpoint to me so it's
the first part but I'm with you on the
second part like I am in pocket with you
on the second part like you just took me
back to glass needles and again that
that's to to nullify the penalty of
double R and G right give the players a
double it's more yeah you're boring
I'm being nice right it's more than mm G
so it's like give us that ability to say
hey I like especially exotics because
let's be real you know the drop rate for
exotics right now are so you know small
you're stuck with what you stuck with
you know I mean so if it's not the
affinity you need to your build you're
screwed I mean it just it is what it is
so that's the first part I mean
completely I guess the other part of get
them chill at chill time like I know how
they think man their whole thing and
they said it time and time again with as
far as boss melting and listen it's some
of the funnest things ever
I enjoy it you know when you got some
good strats and you know stuff like that
as far as stacking the the abilities and
stuff like that no doubt it's fun but I
think their fear it's not even I think
is I know their fear is us running
through content as fast as we are
and it sucks as a hardcore player do you
understand your sentiment Eddie because
it sucks as a hardcore player because
you know what you used to be able to do
and it's not like you've been brought
down to your exact like sixth grader
status against a bully but for the sake
of you know balance I rather it then
them creating artificial things like The
Reckoning like to me the reckoning was a
pure example of they don't know how to
control us so cuz we're just got these
crazy strats and we stacking these
abilities and we've got these powerful
things so now let's put snipers all the
way on both sides attacking you forcing
you to do Wells and stuff like that and
I think from a design constraint and
maybe they just got to get better at it
you know they just don't know how to
handle thing I think this new mentality
when it started started from that and
now it's trickling down into this with
the exactly it could be fun but if they
if they these guys come up with these
combos you can say we won't be able to
control in we're trying they're in this
stage where they're just honestly trying
to control and space out the content and
some people gonna have an issue with
that some people gonna feel it's
artificial but I think that's just with
I think that's where the mindset is I'm
not saying I completely agree with it
all the way but I think that's what in
my cities but you go you know I think I
think I agree with that I think that's
that's pretty spot-on I mean I kind of
agree with you guys on all those fronts
it's like but in turn it's like it's not
a test server I know they're never gonna
have that as an option you have steam
table other do test servers but it's
like could they like I feel like the
exotic armor would be a harder thing to
put mods into than exotic weapons even
because the weapons themselves could be
they're still like they bounce those by
damage numbers and mechanics and what
they do and again just the mechanics of
all the weapon ones all you do is I
think a faster reload by your armor that
you put somewhere else or you break a
shield or break a barrier or whatever
that is mm-hmm if you go to the armor
side then you see things like thunder
coil paired with oppressive darkness on
a crown of tempest like so and that's
not even the right combination of
elements there but all those things
could be game breaking so I could see
them doing baby steps at least a little
bit but I'm also at the point of like
the affinity that you have so many
oranges because you have first you have
to try and get the exotic yeah that's
hard enough then you have to try and get
a good stat role and the ranges on those
stats can go all over the place so
that's two already three is you have to
get like and then yeah there's useless
um
and then you've got where the stats are
old that's three and then when you add
affinity on to that as Teddy was saying
you're like oh my that's like we're just
mmm
you know we're past cubing at this point
we're at too high of a power the
exponent is too high way too many
multipliers and it's just like oh
because I mean they say if you won't
player choice but you as you're saying
like the player choice I feel like there
was the little graphic runaround I've
seen at reference and a couple different
things and just
graphics of the little mouse like
crawling over the top of the maze yeah I
don't know if anybody saw that on
Twitter in the last week or so and game
developers like make the maze and then
speedrunners like walk across the top of
it and go all the way over it's like
that stuff's always going to happen mmm
and there are and I they they look at
the dados and they look like the people
who break down the numbers and here's no
one who even typically breaks the game
but even once you like speedrun or three
men and stuff like that it's cool to
watch but the amount of your overall
player base that might actually break
the game versus the people who casually
log in don't have a hundred and twelve
thousand triumph score yeah I didn't
know the number I was guessing haha but
it's like that number versus like all
the free people how many people like
look at my video of how to level up and
be like hey this is like a new player
coming and just constantly still gonna
come in they don't know about half of
that crap and for them they just have
like 17 RNG random rolls of systems
would be like I don't even understand
it's not fun I can't pick what I want to
and then how long do you keep him around
it's like making I think one of the
things that shot division one that most
mm-hmm early on was catering it too much
to streamers because it was the
economy's and they made him a lot harder
to get and then the average person who
doesn't play like a crazy amount of
hours wasn't able to keep up with like
the crafting and stuff like that because
the gear the materials were so hard to
come by and then in this it's like we
don't have materials but we have so many
dice rolls that come into it
it takes a normal person like a chance
to get one or two exotics so much longer
than the person who's running
980 nightfalls with a stacked group it's
like and so what if they break it how
they want to try and get people into the
game more and more people into this
thing that's why that will get to the
power level stuff a little bit later
which is a completely different
conversation but all of those pieces
it's just like they're they're trying to
spend too many plates and then they try
to handle the plates to the player and
weak and it's just like it's too much so
I don't agree I mean I agree with you I
don't agree with whatever what they're
doing I just think it's one of those
things where you know in in their
defense again I think community is also
each one teach one
because let's be real if we have a strat
you know that thing starts to spread you
know it starts to spread I mean think
about this the reason why I know they're
on that mentality is because this was
the first the last couple of seasons
where they've been extremely agile when
something is broken from an exotic
standpoint like they got to shut it down
button now right right now before what
was the exotic that the Telesto Telesto
was hammer the nails back in yeah like
now it's like boom hammering it good at
the docks Cooney who we had on the show
got a great article on that whole
mentality I think it's just
unfortunately that's just where they are
they we have to look at their actions
right because sometimes they're not
forthcoming all the time and their
actions to me dictate balancé balancé
balancé hold on just can't get out of
control and in again the only reason why
I think I a little sad with certain
aspects is because I'm a puller I will
pull it in fully boxes now to do these
things on their own and we have to let's
go my developing content making weapons
and adding all new things in the game
not in the way systems works that it's
just a choice by how big or small the
team is that doesn't matter you could
have a hundred people you get have five
people if they make a bad decision
that's still on however many people are
making that decision so they're never
going to keep up that is one thing I
think everybody needs to understand is
they will never make enough for it to
last they are trying to get better at
spacing what they can they're adding
bosses in over the calendar which we'll
look at but like things like when we're
talking about RNG and random roles and
stuff like that that is not
a choice for the playerbase this is
great big debate we always had a good
app it's not apples to apples you're
correct it's not apples I totally
enjoyed this is a show within the show
continued sir I've got a I've got a
second hot chick here I mentioned this
before the podcast but uh I cover a
background of completion alike when I
play games why I triumph on it's kind of
engraved into my DNA because of Nintendo
and how their games are designed and you
kind of just always want to get
everything right and and at least a
Nintendo games most of the time the
collectibles are usually worth it but
yeah so at its core if you were to break
destiny down if you were to strip all
the game away all the mechanics what is
dess it's a it's a inventory management
game like an inventory management and
resource gathering game and with that
comes time management right so we're
talking about you know how burning
bosses and and you know the optimal
Stratos will always find the fastest way
to do everything because the fastest way
yields more resources more gear more
armor more mats whatever happy right and
your time is valuable so I sympathize a
Bungie a little bit because I know that
they it's impossible no one could do
this no studio could do this where they
could test for every possible scenario
that the playerbase could could come up
with and and I get it on one hand you
know they don't want this bad reputation
of of the game is broken or something's
actually not functioning but then again
- like it's just we're just having fun
right like it's a PvE PPP's a different
discussion and I think that's a that's a
harder balancing act for them both
literally and metaphorically but for PvE
like I don't know I just just let me let
me let me do things as fast as I want to
do them like you take the fanatic strike
for example right that basta cannot melt
at all it's impossible but knockers who
has a similar mechanic you could melt
him if you're fast enough from from one
zero yes that should just be an option
on every boss like if we're and if we're
good enough we can skip the mechanic if
we're not then you just you just let it
go like you just doing the mechanic and
you do it like normal anyway go ahead
that was my last no we we we we killing
his atopic guys as long points I mean
this low flick today
the point is I think the way this is
what I remember and I always go back to
vanilla d2 as my reference point and
I'll never forget they were of multitude
of mistakes with vote with the fidelity
to we won't go into that but I feel
destiny sometimes I think the lesson
that we have to learn from vanilla d2 is
that when the player base gets what they
want they check out and part of the
problem with vanilla d2 not saying that
everything was easy but a lot of things
were accessible right so what happened
is a lot of the player base they come in
you know they were getting raid weapons
from Hawthorn they were doing a whole
bunch of things and at that point the
philosophy was like the items or
whatever it was instead of some of the
challenge of pinnacle activities and
stuff like that and I think it's just
it's tough balancing act man is it's
tough because I think what happens is
look I love melting bosses I loved
everything you're saying take like
everything you say it's fun you get in
here you got the optimal scratch and
people are going to find the optimal
strats but I worry that when we knock
only stuff down and everybody's getting
these pinnacle rewards what's the
incentive to keep playing I think part
of what max - Deniz great is the chase I
decide that you know to get it you go
into town like man how did he branches
get that what did he do for that right
now do I want it to be like Anarchy when
I'm looking at destiny Gary and he's
like I still haven't gotten an
earthiness my 55th score is run you
yet it has to be balanced but I think
that's the only reason why I do sigh
with them slightly because I know how I
am when I have everything I'm kind of
done I'm like okay you know I'll tune
back in when you know the next thing is
added and I I do like it is it
artificial probably so you know I'm
stretching it but it's a tough balance I
do feel for them on the PvE side
I definitely feel for them it's so tough
there they're a pendulum and they they
always tend to swing one way too far and
then when they when they correct
they always from the other way too far
but those rare instances where they hit
that middle point it's that it's the
magic right it's it's that it's it's
where destiny shines its brightest one
day when they get that when they get it
right and I think that's that's why we
always come back because it's it's a
hope right like maybe they got it right
but anyway if we need to move on we
couldn't like for me it's just the point
of I know you're saying they want to
manage our time but in he says it's a
little force but I'm in my mind it's
more than just a little bit forced mm so
it's to the point of as like you watch
some of the people that I mean the does
the Destin's out there counting is
anarchy drums and stuff like that that's
gonna be one of those somebody else had
like a cross-stitch made because he had
more than a hundred runs still not
getting any anarchy which is brutal
but not even that it's just like at the
point we are at now you guys are both
saying it's like why do we play video
games at a very very basic level to have
fun into a point of when certain things
in this game are not fun that in that
gets it that one of the deepest issues
where destiny has some trouble with its
balance and is it a balance of your time
versus the other hey should this boss
have six immunity phases even if I hit
him in the head with a four times hone
shot oh like if I take off a chunk of
his health and it's half his damn bar
and we hit him all at the same second
hey maybe he dies in to immunity faces
like certain things as you said knockers
you could knock him out if you time it
right and if you've actually learned how
to do that
why
punish the player for getting that
precision guys it's like okay we're
running as a team three two one
bomb oppressive darkness war Clicquot
but have done late if you can get that
together how many teams actually put
that together all the time
how many average players go through a
strike on the other side each one teach
one
what's once the secret get out everybody
everybody doesn't as a everybody how big
of this everybody of the population are
you talking about because you have
hardcore people that actually pay
attention to the red it's the YouTube
threads and people that just log in and
play file it your valid if you're
looking from a percentage standpoint
from the whole but again I'm gonna apply
your same mentality with your your
favorite event your the dungeon guy
could you imagine shot it thrown guys
come up with a milk strap right
everybody's running around wish and
everyone's running around with that
stuff what's the incentive to go back in
again I'm just thinking for mystic what
if we're blazing through content so fast
that's their fear no but I'll be it's
like it usually again with those type of
strats we're gonna get the loot very
fast you know I'm saying and again all
I'm saying is I just remember the
reasons why I checked out of d2 vanilla
I had everything
sofa then I didn't even step in the raid
or certain aspects I had stuff but
that's another story but now okay let me
flip it to the other side do you think
you can get anything at this point like
be specific what you mean okay you you
want an exotic with a intellect
discipline role in arc of finiti how
hard so you know you're writing oh
absolutely I was like is it has it as he
as Teddy said the pinyon how far away
has its long when you had everything now
it's almost impossible to get exact to
go for that thing that you really want
but I think those are two separate
arguments one versus difficulty versus
this terrible triple quadruple orangey
but okay so here's the thing is like if
they have swung so far that is really
hard to get the quadruple orangey hmm
why do you have to make it still really
hard for me to go through the activity
I can burn a boss faster and I get two
more chances at said drop when I have
six thousand time I see one in sometimes
if it's hard to get it then make me then
don't hamper my efficiency if it's easy
if you want if they want to keep you
doubt this is where we meet now now I'm
with you now if they want to keep this
if they are so hell-bent with this
affinity and Armand they don't want it
to go then I do agree yes they do need
to give us at least multiple options
kind of like almost when Menagerie did
that thing when they had you know that
week and it's like three or four drops
said it was like it was raining out
there for a little bit you know I'm
saying because even though you got those
drops you still weren't guaranteed the
roles the infinity or whatever it is so
in that I'll meet you in the middle
there with that part for sure I said
he's talked about drops for Menagerie
and that is this kind of many stories so
I there's specific the shotgun Imperial
decree is specific role that I was
chasing a free Guardian con yes I uh I
made an excel sheet after the first one
hundred not surprised I I had about five
hundred drops chasing one very specific
role the barrel didn't really matter it
was no another barrel the muzzle own
about assault mag trench barrel full
auto full auto increases fiery by ten
percent assault Megan creases fire rate
by five and the trench barrel obviously
and this is when Tector and I close were
still kind of somewhat used Mountain
tapas at its prime so you know what's
her but it was better than both those
guns with that role I did it over six
hundred times I still don't have the gun
so there is something to be said about
yes menagerie was very rewarding and it
was great that it was dropping all that
stuff but if the game is somehow
actively working against me and did not
giving me the thing I want and that's uh
hurts a little makes me not want to put
the game he said that the hardcore
player you know desire versus the I feel
for them sometimes purses the casual fan
to get in it's tough it's - I definitely
nothing you guys are saying is wrong you
know saying I I just think it's I just
feel for them on certain aspects cuz
this is a very difficult game to balance
angry you know I'm just gonna leave
Prescott's coming out there just cuz I
gave him a hard time about that going on
but yeah so like we obviously got off on
a big tangent there but I mean it's been
a journey since shadow keep started we
have this brand new armor system yes
we've got stats we've got rolls we've
had different strikes we've got exotics
that do and don't come and d'azyr's
still just the technical face man of
uselessness occasionally all those
things happen he's gonna be a little
useful now going forward because you get
you buy that faded AM grin every week
and it's it's gonna be armor if you have
all the weapons I wanted good armor for
so long and I it still has potential but
it's not there yet not there that sense
I guess where I'll just leave it so
faith but yeah back to season have gone
after joys of tangents and that's what
we do here on so I don't know if you
know Teddy our podcasts used to be
called flashpoint mmm I do not even
theory it was mint like flashpoint but
generally is you know flash being quick
but then we head over to our podcast
we're like we're in a long point now and
that is exactly what this is today's
good or anybody who's been around for a
little while we passed the flash a long
time ago so next in the stream we also
got the shortest preview of the calendar
ever here's the calendar there goes the
calendar go find it on Twitter later on
which is also kind of odd so what'll
kind of walk through the calendar with
you guys
I'm gonna have it up on screen so you
guys are chatting in twitch I will get
back to y'all but for the calendar I
can't I want to go through this one for
you guys see what you guys think about
it and then we'll get into the table
stuff towards the end so one launch day
we have saint-14 starin at us we've got
the new sundial pvp mode and the sundial
this is where they start to mention I
guess our boss rotation vbe sorry the
sundial night rule the hollow voice is
our first one don't know what he looks
like we can see a couple of the others
free to all destiny two players we get
the new seasonal artifact which is not
in the season pass by the way so I don't
know if that's just gonna come from
Osiris's here's the lantern I'm not
entirely sure but is not in the season
which I'm honestly fine with because
playing seven levels of the season pass
and then finally giving an artifact kind
of was annoying so I'm glad hopefully it
just comes earlier solar subclass
updates PvP mode elimination we'll talk
about your PvP stuff don't worry new PvP
map tangled Shore and Mars obelisks open
they have told us nothing about those
obelisks and those are for everybody
yeah solve them are some of them are for
everyone right for obelisks are for
everyone all for pottery here yeah and
then the necessary DZ on the 17th is
also for everybody
okay so honestly you have people who are
like hey I've you know I haven't bought
the season yet what do I get if I don't
buy the season it might be a nice thing
to tease one of these things as well
what's an obelisk or this thing and they
may have a secret but it's starting
right on day one so some people are
gonna see it some aren't what do you
guys think as that's kind of thing we
haven't seen yet what do you guys think
these are gonna be there's gonna be four
four different planets what do you guys
think this is going to do function
mechanical eyes what do you guys expect
I would guess it's probably just their
their version of the world event this
the season so kind of like the the
wolves on on Mars or what if it was from
destiny one and the higher nights I know
people been asking for that for a long
time for that to come back and we we
sorta got that with the forges with the
the shielded guys but yeah they were
tied to a quest and after you completed
the quest and killed them once you kind
of never had to do it again unless
you're doing like a bounty or something
so I imagine it's something like that
but maybe a little more in depth
I don't know that it I'm surprised I
didn't say anything about it I'm maybe
but they want us to discover it maybe
it's a puzzle thing over a combat thing
I don't know what do you guys think this
is the most obscure road map ever like
I'm just like I'm not that I'm like
upset with it it just there's no
information there's no reference points
so the only thing I can think about it's
kind of like what Jenny said like he's
got to be similar type of world events
and you know with this whole árboles
thing and then as far as their me
obviously I always get into the you know
the Sundown stuff like that which feels
very boss you know fighting issue you
know I don't know you know I'm saying
again my only concern is just that I
just we know me and you've talked to you
before and we know most likely this
there was gonna be a rain right we know
most likely it wasn't gonna be a dungeon
we just had that we have to be
respectful of the resources on hand you
know again the only the only fear I have
is when people are this quiet how much
do you really have to offer and I'm a
little concerned I'll be honest I am a
little concerned I'm again this stuff
could be great you know I could do all
my my fears can be unfounded it's just
you know it feels like you're like and
here's the other thing I want to shout
out there too you know we gotta be real
here to in a standpoint this is a ten
dollar expansion so to speak right and I
will say this as much as my fears is and
stuff like you know it's as much of an
ornament yeah well yet so bad right you
know shout to the iron bear the guys who
got to tend Olivetti you do I it I'm a
lord I got to do it little you know in
fairness I have to say this I think we
are all agreed I respond at any honest
that you know season of the undying we
could have missed and been okay with
shadow keep if so technically it didn't
exist right
we happened we got everything but it was
very light so in comparison to undying
to dawn not shadow keep the dawn season
I've gone but I'm dying to dawn yes this
is you know seems to be way much more
you know saying going on here yeah and
you know that's what I meant
I'm just gonna I'm gonna temper
expectations because my fear is the
stuff may be very late compared undying
you go what do you have you literally
have different public events and you
have one arena basically I mean that's
literally all undying had right I'm
gonna go spend a lot of time in that
thing for the damn title but that's
gonna be a sad weekend for me anyway
like a dog a whole lot of Netflix and
Netflix in game but yeah it's like if
you start pulling stuff out of this
calendar of what is going to be actually
content so take sundial sundial sundial
those are three different bosses they
could have different mechanics but
that's all of us there so that's one
roll off the top you have the dawning
which is for a month which most of us
will be done in about a week so that's
still more just a holiday event if you
guys can hear my wolf sorry but
apparently there's someone outside
crimson days pvp still probably
shouldn't advertise with sparrows if
they're not going back with bear racing
league so get that if SRL doesn't come
back alright like the fact that they
have sparrows on here twice really is
like poor advertising if it's yes so so
last year they did the same thing the
the picture had the sparrow but they
were advertising the sleigh thing yeah
and when it didn't come I was like it's
been two years
I love s RL i played i played mario kart
competitively and sro is just mario kart
without yes there's no items right so
it's pure skill like yeah what's a minor
there's a minor that makes me use my
controller so you all know use my
controller because i was actually pretty
good at the sparrow racing league on
playstation so yeah i played a lot of
sparingly
both years on on destiny 1 and if that
isn't srl like put a snowflake in there
and put a heart and the other one and
get the sparrows out of the damn
pictures I'm sorry but yeah that's not I
don't expect it to be Sparrow Racing
League but that is the biggest tease
that they can do Amanda a job fixing the
same Sparrow for rotations in there like
build one every seat what if she just
had one be like hey I'm gonna give you
this long like triumph that you got to
do over the course of killing 500,000
enemies over the course of the season
I'm gonna use all those parts and build
a sparrow this season just something
random for her cause she's so sad over
in the tower
Cades gone the faction guys don't really
do anything they've left the building or
taken out so older that side less or is
there yeah
and I really go for him just add a
connoisseur all because it's it's my
favorite one of my favorite things are
destiny and if it doesn't come back man
it's gonna hurt take the three bosses
out of the right of this page you can
take iron banner which is probably not
the only iron banner we'll cover that in
a minute
take crimson days take the dawning off
of there
what new content do we have with a Sun
Dial the hard version and whatever
Imperium foundation is and that is three
months yeah so it's like if you you have
a PvP PvE mode with potentially four
different bosses maybe cool because the
Saiyans are always cool you have a
difficulty to it and we have exotic
quests which may be cool we'll see way
if you're wondering if it's light if
this is what we have they haven't told
us what the final three weeks are this
is gonna save that for another
discussion little point here in a second
I think you're honestly you're suspect
of like what is the $10 season you're
looking at it yeah so I don't think
they're I think they're tempering
expectations in the stream may not have
been intentional may not have been their
best stream but I think that honestly
maybe
a kind of silver lining for them to
temper what everybody's like hey uh okay
okay it's kind of about what I thought
like people didn't get too high over the
top I think maybe save the legend which
is going to be cool but go ahead and
Teddy let me ask is this so so now that
we've had this will be our fifth
seasonal drop in destiny - do you guys
prefer this kind of seasonal time gated
system or or your first do you prefer
the Destiny one where it was like
everything was front-loaded with the
first three six months the season and
then we get like it like a spring
updated update and then nothing after
that until the next expansion how do you
like which one do you prefer and why you
just opened up a whole have debated so
long it's so funny you pretend you got
to be dying this is the battle yeah I
mean it's listen I'm always gonna be a
fan of expansions that's just how that
is just how my mind works with destiny
that's just how I've been conditioned
you know in ease defense I do understand
why seasons so to speak had to happen
and as far as I'm from a studio
standpoint and as far as cadence and
content you got I mean but you know put
it this way the last season's that we've
had right which we had black armory
drifter opulence out of all of those
opulence was the only one I felt
satisfied with for the most part
opulence was the one that I felt if
seasons can replicate that I won't
complain right now grant it I know every
season can't have a raid I know every
season can't have a dungeon and I'm
saying so I get it but um it's tough man
because as a destiny hardcore player
I love playing this game all the time
right and now it's like you know as a
season you know it's like tune in come
in for a minute
chill do a couple things and activity
and then I see you later and it's weird
it's weird playing other games and I
know II we've gone back and forth with
this you know saying but um you know for
me God would love nothing but to play
test me all the time you know say but I
understand also the logistics of it it's
hard right and now the again there's no
Vicarious Visions you know there's no hi
moon this is all them they are the big
independent you know um studio I just
wish part of me does think though what
if they still kept the old cadence and
went two expansions I don't know man I
III almost might say hey I'd wait you
know said if they were very they were
packed heavy you don't saying and then
you know you wait for a bit you go to a
drought
you know after shadow keep or whatever
and then it's like okay come back at the
top of the year it's it's tough man it's
icy you vagabond with the slander stop
it I see you with the one character well
Iceland I see but here at the end of the
day man it's a tough thing I I
personally like expansions if you're
gonna put a gun to my head I will always
say expansions like shot to me shadow
keep represented the traditional model
yeah right and I love that it was tons
of things to do I love my mind
overwhelmed it even if there's a drought
now and let's just say the next shadow
keep kind of thing was like at the top
of the year you know I'm saying or you
know spring or whatever I'm kind of okay
with that but it's like this model here
I struggle because you see the potential
right but I don't know I'm not getting
the raid I know I'm not getting the
dungeon you know and then we just got to
hope that this stuff is really good and
that's all I'm hoping for operas but
just don't feel like a blister I don't
even know where this is that like this
is this is somewhere between armory and
drifter maybe I don't know so after
probably a bug drifter right you know
simply I'll give it to II you know that
I can go on forever on this you know
kind of thing
I'm curious to see where he's at now if
he kind of maintains the same stance I
mean mines but you you have nicely
turned the tables because when you step
away and you're like hey and play in
outer wilds and you love it now you like
you're doing that while this content is
going on like this and if you had your
bigger I know it's like now if you had
your bigger brakes like we talked about
and you're like hey let me play it all
okay let me go play my other games hey
let me come back and play all this new
stuff okay I'll go try something else
for a little while like the bigger
brakes are sometimes healthy for some of
us because there's this like destiny is
like never gonna win this battle yeah no
matter what they do if they do this
seasons and they're only one studio and
they don't have 6,000 developers in
there that they can afford to keep
running and put out some crazy amount of
content it's never gonna be enough and
then if there's a drought then people
fall off and then how much you do keep
going so they have basically swimming
uphill both ways in the snow it's not
gonna work well and they're trying to
make the most of it if I had to choose I
mean I think the expansion's typically
do offer more and that's kind of like
we're in the same boat dude I was like
because there are times the seasons are
cool because if they get to a point
where the seasons are like Luke
described ada walks in the tower
we've got more interaction with that she
leaves there's this narrative connection
and it gets to that dream that we hope
for then that has the potential for the
narrative if there was content to go
with the narrative then I think that
would actually give it a really cool
feel and then like those are small or we
know they're smaller they keep the story
going it's kind of fresh and then you
get to the big thing that comes next
fall yes but if the content does have
lacking points like drifter black arm
room is cool big lag and then opulence
was pretty cool it's just the
consistency and it's hard for them to
probably okay what's this next narrative
thing we're gonna do what's the new
activity we're gonna build
that is that it was just one new
activity and then do people get tired of
still running strikes and gambit and
other things and then you think about
the titles is like for Teddy out there
it's like we'll give it back to you in a
second but it's like I'm thinking about
this title more than half of this title
grind was me running strikes playing
gambit matches collecting the ritual
weapons for the season that doesn't make
me undying that just means I had no life
for a little while that's literally all
that one's gonna mean and that's where
it's kind of like some of the things
they some of those things they make you
do in this game make you almost a pretty
L like enjoy the seasons less it was
just like hey the seasons kind of cool
there's the thing go kill a million vex
hey you've done this thing made me get a
cool emblem for it as opposed to go get
one point eight million kills in strikes
675 arc ability kills 275 melee kills
where I had to go there's my hammer I
got a really fun combo on that one by
the way I ended up using four it was the
sole so it's the vanguard emblems that
you need and you had like this nightfall
points that you need or whatever but you
also have to get solar kills but melees
I accidentally had my dude marches on
and it was helping helping somebody out
with the video mm-hmm so I had those on
and when you sprint you get the little
melee like static electricity but then I
was trying to get solar melee so is on
my Titan so it's throwing my hammer when
I threw my hammer after sprinting the
Lightning would spread from where it hit
yeah so it actually was this kind of
chain effect that made it go a lot
quicker and I just like I was actually
kind of fun when I stumbled into that
point but it still I had to go do like
one last sector over and over and over
and over and it's like they they almost
make it to the point where it's like a
season I might have enjoyed by the time
I get done trying to keep up with
everything that's in it
I probably almost looked down upon it
because of what it made me do you poked
at a really really big kind of go into
that better grind for the triumph right
so like I was saying earlier that the
best players and just the community at
large will always find the most optimal
way to do something right and so you're
talking about like you have your dude
mark
design you got this ability going and
like when I was working on undying I
knew going into that I was like this
this is an unreasonable amount of things
that I have to do and I mean I don't
have to do them but I'm gonna of things
that you know I got I gotta get all
these ability kills on the moon I got
you know this ability kills and strikes
and they're not retroactive and and all
these weapon kills index offensive that
makes me a complete detriment so if
you're playing with and and they're
doing the same thing to so then it just
makes the activity take twice as long
and and it it just creates this weird
environment of like and and I know that
I'm like in the super minority when it
comes to triumph hunting so this is like
a super small or superb it's a major
gripe of a small amount of people but
like I'm doing the altar of sorrow
triumph right now for getting five
hundred waves which is the final trial I
need for the for the season to hit max
more and if you think about it 500 waves
is just a lot of altar of sorrow it's a
lot of death
I was I was crunching the numbers last
night while I was playing it and it was
something like you have to do 400 waves
cuz it's a hundred to get to rank for
but so far our waves and it wasn't like
25 hours of playing or something like
that and I'm like am I gonna do this am
I really gonna do this might and then
and then today I was thinking about it
right before we started the podcast and
I'm like man my my time is really not
valued when it comes to this stuff so
going back to the undying things where
I'm leading into this let's go I feel
like when it comes to those kinds of
triumphs or those kinds of
accomplishments for a quest or something
that they're not really then I don't
know this for sure this is just me
speculating but I don't I feel like
they're not testing how long those
things take because yeah let's let's be
real here not everyone is as good as we
are or even there's better players than
us but like we're gonna we're gonna try
and do everything as optimally as
possible but the average player if you
look at it on a bell curve the average
player they're not gonna get undying
they're not gonna get those tramps then
they're not gonna get those kills done
in time because they're just casually
hey using that word but they're just
casually playing the game and I think
that when they they talk a lot about
especially a guardian con they talked a
lot about respecting the players time
it's one thing to say it it's another
thing when I go into the game and you
show me this title that I'm gonna get it
right like I'm gonna go in the title and
it's like alright this is gonna take me
15 hours of X offensive I'm gonna try
and not hang myself and is like and and
it's this weird double-edged sword man
like I always complain about it and then
they give me they get me every time I
think the completion is in US or the
hard floor makes us do it but again I
think you nailed it I think there
there's still some discrepancy of
missing a boat with the whole the time
investment and like for example like a
title I really want that I know most
like I'm not gonna have as blacksmith
and it's just like oh that was wrong and
think about now it's like 500 kills at
your tomb 500 kills with Izanagi and
then it's like well now the forgers
rotate you know I'm saying it's like it
did so many different layers and it's
just like at the end of the day you know
I rather I forgot who said it another
content creator said it I rather the
triumph be tied to like something like
eat what about is does which is like
okay you know you so load a thing like
something that required a skill involved
with it as opposed to just a repetitive
action of you know just on elongated
repetitive action 500 kills like are
they really looking at the metrics as in
reference to the time investment
required to do that because that is a
lot like you said the casual you know
they're not gonna be able to do that but
it's not because it really is difficult
did you got to sacrifice your life to do
this that's just really what it is it's
not is not a title of skill it is no
skill tinea I mean
Randy's 13 knife you gotta get 2100
glory I've heard it he might shadows of
my brother he knocked it out so I'm like
I'm hoping it goes relatively smoothly
for me but maybe he's just better anyway
that is roto yeah
it's back this week which was a nice
little touch but most of that is
literally just time and that's like I
mean as I forget who said it in chat I
was dying when they said it they're like
it's undying it's because you're gonna
be zombies by the end you just spending
too much time he just died and destiny
it's just that's the point of like
respecting the players time is one of
those things they still have to consider
when it comes to some of these things
for you to do 500 waves I think we get
the point
don't you've spent your time in altar of
sorrow right like that that shouldn't be
triumphs score just to be like oh we got
one hundred two hundred six thousand
waves later this man lost his mind not
cool now to put photos advocate to my
own point I I completely understand that
not like I'm not saying every title
should be you know super hard to get or
difficult but the thing that makes
undying kind of unique is that it's the
first of its kind
I guess the 2019 one was kind of like
this too but it goes away you cannot
earn that title not after the fact so so
personally I would rather have a easy
mindless title to grind if it goes away
at the end of the season versus like if
you told me to get unbroken three times
in one season and then it goes away
forever I'd be like bro so you know I I
see where they're coming from so I'm
hoping that this season's title is a
little bit better but we've kind of
strayed away from the the road map out
let's get back on track hopefully I was
gonna ask real quick while I get the
road map back up what do you guys think
the new title will be called because I
have an idea I don't know well me or you
guys think first - no I'll think of
something Saint dawn doesn't make sense
yeah that's like that doesn't like dawn
or let's just it now on the reindeer
like so it's like I've been trying to
what it would be dawn the disciple of
Osiris disciple you just sitting there
with brother Vance like a crazy person
right get your fan boy or the Empyrean
is how you pronounce it the I could see
my doing that
I don't know say it say it actually
seems pretty it seems pretty good
we'll see cross my fingers because that
actually would be kind of cool Saint
Saint kognito so we got the obelisk for
free those are pretty early and we've
got these four bosses and if you look at
so we're back on the calendar if you
guys are following along since I can't
really put on screen so we have now roll
the hollow voice and when you looked in
the trailer at one point you did see one
of these guys who had no masks on
Kabbalah nasty-looking without their
masks on by the way they're gross the
silent oh they are cabal but they're
kind of like the grunts from halo oh
they're there they're enslaved by the
Cabal they're theirs so they're they're
not technically the same race but they
are cabal like the Covenant god I might
be watching that a little bit cuz I'm
not like super familiar with the lore
but I think that's that's what it kind
of boils down to is that's but they do
look nasty out there it might be him in
the trailer but then we go to sundial ah
slick the sky piercer very much looks
arc related yes then we've got the
sundial Taz rock - the sun-eater gonna
guess he's solar related now process of
elimination nairo might be void in the
only reason I say that is because when
we look at the bottom on you know Tom
Oblivion's triune when we see the piece
of the trailer with the broken shattered
glass and all of that stuff he has that
monochromatic color scheme to him he
doesn't have he's black white and gray
he is not blue red purple orange nothing
he is basically nothing and I'm
if he because we have this big break of
legend of sundial which is the hard mode
which is no matchmaking that one comes
out about a month later mm-hmm and then
about a month after that in February we
get the Imperium foundation which looks
like we're going to the past and but it
also looks like the portal to the
infinite forest is closed and then we've
got this guy who might be in this broken
timeline so I'm kind of wondering how
they use the sundial the transitions the
bosses and stuff like that and I kind of
wondered if you guys had me had broken
it down this far I had thought about
like the implications of the flag solar
arc void and this other I don't know
what he's gonna be so I didn't know if
you guys had thought about that that
much are you looking forward to the
different bosses do you think it's like
one one week 1 we get one week two we
get another week three we get another
and then six weeks later we get the last
one it's also weird cadence yeah I mean
I think for me um you know I don't I
don't mind this aspect I will shout out
the hunters though hunters you got to
make a quest that y'all better get Chuck
yeah you know what you call it your
marks with that Rover the classic or
Sunday the cloak the sea dancer they
meet they just hunters need to get some
sea dances style clothes this is the
perfect opportunity for Bungie to reward
hunters with this so that's all I got to
say in reference to the cosmetic aspect
but for us the bosses yeah I think your
honor he you know it's gonna be probably
different um elements you know I
remember them vaguely saying something
about you know travelling to different
locations that this DLC will not I mean
expression will not be um tied
specifically always and mercury and then
we will have to go different places I
don't know if that's tide whether the
campaign portion or also in reference to
that but I'm getting them vibes I'm
getting Bob so we shall see you know I
think you gotta hit it I'm actually
looking at the black armory roadmap
because this is a similar similar dates
black armory launched on December 4th
and then it ended on December 4 shortly
I'm sorry ended on February 5th with
crimson days there's a lot less content
in the black armory roadmap
but it's kind of it kind of lines up I
can I can put it in our just squared
thinks you guys can look at it with me
here but yeah it kind of it kind of
lines up pretty similarly to season the
dawn since the dawn actually has a
little bit more going for it than the
black and red but in terms of like in
terms of like spacing it's small that's
the same like dawn I've no rain yeah I
was pretty opposed to the time gated
model when they when they kind of
started introducing it with taking king
and after that it got it got a little
more intense but as I've gotten older
and and I've I've been playing a lot of
Destiny I kind of appreciate it in a
weird way because it's yeah it's almost
like alright
it's like my schedule for destiny yeah
this thing's coming I can either ignore
this or you know tackle it the next week
or I can I can do it and and if you know
if it's not good then it's fine right
like and I usually am unable to play
immediately on Tuesday when things
launch so you know go on read it see
what people are thinking and it's like
okay I don't have to do this or I can
wait till Friday to do this or whatever
right and so yeah I think you nailed it
it seems like each one is a different
boss different devour different type
hopefully it's like menagerie where
they're they're pretty different and the
mechanics are a little bit challenging
but given that they're all Saiyans
I'm not holding that I'm not holding my
breath for that yeah I mean that's kind
of we'll just kinda have to see where
that lays out I do want to say some
people wondering hey how come I own
banner is only on there one time is it
gonna come back they throw that thing in
every which other place they can I'm
sure it's gonna be on the 14th of
January I'm sure it's gonna be somewhere
in the middle of like the end of the
season it's gonna be happening more
often but I really wanted to pick your
guys brain set we know of three exotics
from the season page which is the other
piece of all this crazy amount of
content that we've been looking at one
of those is a sidearm that's where I'm
gonna start it so I wanted to ask and
see you guys thoughts about our first
new exotica the season that we know
about mister sidearm what do you guys
think are you excited are you like crap
I'm pulling it up right now so I can
I looked at it earlier when they when
they launched this and if you want to go
ahead talking you know you can go ahead
tempering expectations you know rat cake
was one that I had high hopes for and
you know I just never even with the box
it never kind of hit that note that I
thought it should I love the concept
though I love the whole you know Rat
Pack six and a crew kind of yeah you
know again you know holdout reserve
judgment till it comes out but I'm not
uh we've got to talk about Bastion
that's the one I'm saving that for now
this this like I'm trying to be nice
like yeah it's the sidearm meta has
never really taken shape but if it does
something cool then all will be forgiven
I'll eat my words right now see what you
see the only freeze-frame I could pull
from the trailers that it will be
potentially a solar side arm that is
literally all because I could see like a
solar wisp in front of it
that's my only guess outside of that I
know nothing listen shout out the
cryptic he said it be VP I can get a gun
out if we can out cutting the clues and
shotguns it's a good asset on if it
offers some type of functionality that
really is cool and unique and powerful
they've got people will use it but now
I'm with kiya like he said let's decide
always making me a great then uh I'm in
the same pocket like if it's not making
me that it needs to do something like it
cannot be some basic you know kind of
perk set it gotta be unique you know cuz
you know the community how we feel but
you think it I just gotta see him with
you guys like I'm not holding my breath
but it's a sidearm it's been a while and
you just have to see it's gonna try and
play devil's advocate and I can't like
I'll put my effort somewhere else it's
not worth it
that upright as you guys started talking
about it I was looking at it and I'm
like how can I make this work and then I
really thought about it I'm like I can't
argue for this like it's I mean I get I
guess if it does something like really
cool then maybe but at the end of the
day it is a sidearm it's just not gonna
be good like I think the last good
sidearm we got was last hope and vanilla
t2 and then trespasser and destiny one
so I don't know okay I'm saving Bastion
for last second one I'm exactly I'm
gonna make you I kind of make you wait
for it to make you uh gonna tease you a
little bit so symmetry or scout rifle
this does seem to be the thing we saw
the trailer am I wrong I think so it
says right the PvP trailer we just like
shoots him in the head a couple times
after landing and then he smashes the
bottom like a honed edge shut and then
it turns into like a fusion rifle yeah
yeah yeah I'm curious what you guys
think on this one what how it could work
if it is a scout rifle which I based on
the photo of the three Guardians holding
it on the page it looks like it is man
that looks awesome but but they make
good trailers right and let's be honest
you're not gonna be getting a seven
column every day yes it looks awesome
and it sounds cool the music's pumping
and it's rusted turns and you're like oh
man but when it comes to exotics like I
said earlier everything for me is about
time management how fast I can do things
and if this exotic doesn't accelerate my
advancement of loot in some way then I'm
not gonna put it on no matter how cool
it is any high days in that trailer III
have been suckered into the height with
you listen if you all you gotta do is
have Shaq's yell out what
Oh real quick sidenote
um all you Titan means I understand say
for Tina's back I get it I understand
the love I get but we back on
disrespected green check ready I've been
seeing some very slanderous comments
about you know say forty needs to kick
Shaq's out and it needs to be safe well
no the order that they get kicked out is
avala goes first
yeah Jackson the Saint can figure out
who still who's like number one number
two but like because of all is
unfortunately not not not holding the
strongman title right now I mean they
they call st. 14 the greatest Titan that
ever lived
so uh is the contest I get it but we've
not gonna disrespect the great shacks
all right we can't as a warlock for that
is to tighten my feet one of my favorite
tights
I just love shake but I just feel
there's a lot of shacks landed or run
out of this their new guys in town he's
back in her in a room you luck salad and
shacks insane who comes out alive
we know st. go win but protocol he saved
the city never forget the law he he the
reason why him a salad that soundings of
Iowa is tight like this but shacks
didn't listen broke the formation of
Porco but he's responsible for save the
city because of his action and now he's
being penalized but anyway I'm done with
my mile already and you're in your
example if Jackson salad and team up you
think they could win
I can't same fourteen cuz they're both
pretty smart Titans like they're not you
know I mean shacks acts a little
abrasive but soudns melon was pretty you
know he's down-to-earth right like he
knows what's going on right like you
think if they teamed up they could they
could take him out very same for teens
they're all gonna punch each other at
the same time and the universe is just
gonna collapse Dragon Ball Z styling
yeah it took like a nation of billions
just to even stop there to figure out so
the whole VEX
de Seine just whenever people you know
forget figuri and there's the big
question mark of all bastian sir
thoughts about this thing besides the
fact that it is absolutely gorgeous
yeah that's a beautiful weapon that is
beautiful
reminds me of the trials your two
weapons the not adept ones though the
the blue ones yes yes complete trials to
aesthetic and looks cool that we have we
confirmed but yeah it doesn't look like
if you it looks like an otter I've heard
unless they're just saying a fusion is
that other the scout rifle but we know
Scouts one and he uses it as a scout
rifle in the PvP match of symmetry like
the guy the Titan in the middle holding
it not yeah that's what people have been
saying it's fusion a lot but I honestly
don't know I don't know I'm excited just
off the aesthetic Illume that looks cool
the only thing we've seen the trailer is
the point where he's looking through a
scope and there's like a symbol of the
eagle and like a Sun and then it light
rotates and like splits apart kind of as
he fires and then it goes white and
can't see anything but there's a frame
those two kind of like line up and then
split I have no idea how it's gonna work
but that's the only thing that would
kind of work because the sight on it is
not enclosed it's not like a fully
enclosed scope and it looks like it's
just kind of got it one of those
projection scopes on it so I think it's
that two seconds you see in the trailer
cuz it's got 14 and the like little
illumination and then but yeah it's like
as they never fire it so I have no idea
what it is somebody said linear fusion
maybe I don't know it is very unique I'm
very curious where they go with that but
yeah I mean shadow town darshan him
showing up the video of like sundial
linear fusion and it's some weapon don't
even know but yeah there's big
speculation I believe linear fusion is
on the mod list for weapons all right
yep this is this one yeah they're
focused a lot more in range in precision
so yes that pretty much covers the
calendar but we have this giant gaping
hole at the end where there's three
weeks of nothing yes I wanted to ask
your opinions on that before I say mine
because
I already threw mine in the video it's
our banner oh yeah just in case you
didn't make max level just pinnacles and
and the bounties rotate on a daily basis
you can get pinnacles daily I can see
the trailer right now someone's do you
just gonna come out is he like yo dawg i
heard you like iron banner and there's
just three weeks of iron banner that's
can someone get deems to say yo dawg
[Music]
there's gonna be at least one week are
better its to be honest I kind of like
it when the season winds down with
nothing at the end cuz it kind of gives
you this time to catch up and you know
if you're missing something or something
you're chasing you can kind of sit down
and be like alright this is what I do
and I have this amount of time it kinda
goes back to that like I hate and like
the calendar because it gives me the
schedule right like it's it's like oh
you know if I'm behind I had this time
and if I do you know so know what you
guys think what do you think's gonna if
they slot anything in their secret
trials maybe I gotta get to tell you I'm
sorry just listen I know trials
realistically is probably not gonna
happen this season all I'm saying shall
to fallout plays out the asked across
the PvP community
oh we're saying you just last season
dropped a trailer talking about renewed
focus right now granted we got to see
what this you know the next week is
gonna bring when the full patch notes or
whatever but it's like ebon don't you
owe me oh my god you know how I'm about
to get cryptic and char you're fine but
it's like man it it just saddens me and
I they need to do something it as a PvP
player person who loves to jump in the
crucible it pains my heart Teddy that I
don't have those pinnacle rewards that
PvE players get you know say like
you know if I invest my time now grant
they alluded to something in this in the
12 that they're gonna think they've been
thinking about it is gonna be some
adjustments but I just need to see it
man because at this point it's just
unfair especially with no pinnacle
activity with trials
so if trials is not coming this season
one we got to be rewarded for time
investment more than the mats more than
you know all that other stuff and it it
really they gotta do something man you
know now all will be all be forgiven if
you jump on its dream or you make an
announcement and you given us you know
like a hard-and-fast date as to when
this is coming on and what you're gonna
do with trial stuff like that you know
but for right now I just got a judge it
as the PvP renewed focus you know they
need to really get that you know saying
and I know we got the table and stuff
but it's just frustrating
it really is frustrating I haven't
played PvP at all because I'm not doing
it for powerful well outside of the
ritual weapons once you've got your
ritual weapon done there's no reason for
me to go in there because I'm not
getting anything for the pinnacle ground
I'm not doing those activities for you
know for powerful gear so that that's
just literally where I'm at with it I
just really really hope it comes sooner
than later just this renewed focus so
let me let me ask you this then since
you're the the new VP guy here and I I
generally I only go into PvP when
there's something I need and then I
checked as soon as I'm done with
whatever I'm doing so do you play iron
banner do you like iron banner yes I
play it because I actually look forward
to it only because and I've had this
discussion with II when I become more of
a solo player recently and it's stuff
one of the only resources I can go in
solo and get pinnacles sure it became an
added value and but don't get me wrong
if you didn't really have that you don't
really wouldn't be ready that as much
and it's not really frequent enough you
know I'm saying so that's just women so
if there's my follow up is if they if
added a title for iron banner would you
be more in sell or my name or radius
Lord cockney got me you won you won
Teddy you won because one
I don't know I've seen this suggested
quite a bit on reddit and the people
I've talked to and I mean III think that
would do a lot for the PC community even
even though it's small right like as a
title hunter and a triumph unter there's
only one pdp-1 like there's only one and
and it's the hardest one to get both by
time and skill needed and I I even
though I'm not a PV person and I don't
necessarily like playing p2p that much I
think it's important that they haven't
having you for something to chase right
it doesn't mean much but it's something
at least at least until trials comes
back right or what if you empathize
appreciate I think that is fantastic to
be honest again you give us again I
wanted a few people who listen we know
try being PBS issues and the people you
know know dedicated servers and we can
go on for days about that and cheating
stuff but you know like the sandbox I
mean it's far from a d1 play into a d2
crucible player I just like the fact
that there's multiple weapons I don't
feel like this
you're always locked in yeah recluse is
good but I always I feel its counters
for everything you know and I still like
the sandbox for the most part and I
would love to get in there but yeah like
if you throw a title in there man oh
yeah like iron banner title
or my other suggestion is comp coppers
in this weird place and it's like I love
the solo queue stuff but how about
pinnacle in there yes like yeah cop is
supposed to be there's no trial so we
have to look at comp as the you know the
pinnacle activity for PvP right now
until trials comes back and the fact
that comp really has nothing except tied
to a couple of trying you know a triumph
one triumph and maybe a couple of
weapons here and there that they try to
make you go into that direction there's
really nothing man it's a didn't shot
the black wouldn't you say they make
hardly rum a solo player as a solo
player I really wish they would at least
give that to calm so I'm gonna hold out
hope I did see some tea leaves yeah we
discuss it reference to I think damage
he mentioned it they looking to do some
shake-up so I'm curious to see how far
they go with said shaker
no I mean I was like for you seriously
like chemicals and PvP are so far from
each other it's kind of sad it would be
nice like what if it's like okay so to
give a little more population there it's
like what if you had to just get like
ten wins for a pinnacle in common
something like that like you don't have
to win them all
there's not like a streak required right
now is a way to you know if you want a
pinnacle and you want to go play comp
that's a way for you to do it I mean
just something as you're saying a title
for a little incentive was perfect
that'd be great
another one that's not just completely
brutal maybe a little bit of PvP
pinnacle I mean people reset their Valor
which you know not isn't always the
hardest thing but if you reset your
value ought to get something for it like
whatever BT visited meeting its two guys
at a big room at Betty empty seat of
people said it's like this renewed PvP
focus like EXO we may as well bring it
up now I mean you have a renewed PvP
focus damage had a good like reply on
Twitter he got pretty candid about it I
don't know if you guys had a chance to
read that one yet no I did you know oh
yeah so he got pretty in-depth just
saying it's like we've tried to we've
had the new director for soloqueue we've
changed some of this stuff up we've
worked on some balancing he kind of had
gone through some stuff but it's also
the balance of how many resources they
have and things of that nature and
there's a lot of things they've got so
he had a decent candid answer out there
it's not the answer that we want right
now but it's the one we just kind of
have to deal with but as you're saying
there's smaller things like titles and a
little pinnacle nodule that's not like I
know some stuffs not easy to program I'm
not a developer I'm not gonna claim to
be effectual but I have a hunch some
things are pretty not difficult to add
in mm-hmm like ten wins for a pinnacle
or iron banner title checking boxes and
tracking things like those things can't
be overly hard to give the PvP side
something else like yeah if there was a
lord title you would have just been oh
like a double thumbs up to it you don't
even care what else is there but if the
title said Lord you're like I'm done I'm
done
this is the best expansion ever best
season ever don't even care I could 500
kill me to death with any weapon out of
[Laughter]
it for the sake of balance and fairness
like again if you're a PvP guy destiny
too is really not the game for you like
it's it's it's so weighted the other way
it is just like me and I love to play
PvP is it perfect no but I do enjoy it
and um you know I've really gotta get to
it man he just got a kick to it you know
so hopefully I'm praying I'm holding out
hope is it isn't it weird that they
marketed D to launch as a competitive
game yeah the calendar does it looks
reasonable I mean for a $10 season it's
definitely gonna have different bosses
will have the empyrion we've got a
couple exotic quests you've got new
mercury weapons with random roles the
time lost weapons they talked about
three different exotics I still have an
issue I'm just gonna say it right now
but by buying the season pass you just
get an exotic right then yeah it still
bugs me a little bit quick question do
you think perfect paradox remains
legendary yes I I think and I don't know
obviously I'm just speculating I don't
know what the story is but I think that
we aren't going to break the timeline in
any way and we're not gonna save
saint-14 I think I think we're gonna
pull him from some timeline and we're
gonna fulfill the the perfect paradox
and end up giving him the gun because
that's what has to happen right what
they've laid out in the lower-right we
at some point we have to give it to him
so that he can go and fight his final
fight and then he can give us the gun
and then you know I love the first
paradox but I think it'll be legendary I
there I think there might be like a
quest or some sort of them like giving
it to you pretty early on quickly so
that you don't have to go do that awful
mercury Quest adventure things great
great adventure like amazing at maze
adventure probably the highlight of
Christmas iris was was yeah doing the
getting the perfect paradox but it's
like gated behind this super bizarre
weapon forging foundry and it just you
know I think they'll just give you the
gun rip flat out if you don't have it
already
Oh on the gun yeah just think perfect
paradox the the fun I think you guys are
pretty well covered it yeah I think
it'll be legendary I don't think they'll
make it in exotic in itself if it's
already been a legendary as it is it's
so weird though because this is again
where the whole time wave rewind yeah
fixing some things much less we may not
fix it but they may fix their time line
to work with I was talking about the
weapon itself being that we've already
acquired said weapon no just interesting
yeah but yeah I mean that pretty much
does wrap up the season look and and it
says here come the bullets so the bullet
points for the swab
I'm gonna save one topic till the end so
you'll notice the very obvious one - Kip
I want to cover a couple highlights
though because they did actually fix a
couple quality life things that I have
to base a big thumbs up - so the exotic
Engram and faded Engram have been
collapsed into a single new exotic item
when opened it Awards a new exotic if
any remain to be collected so you're
working a checklist if any otherwise it
contains a random piece of armor this is
perfect I know you guys can't see double
thumbs up like this is one of those like
somebody like look okay how can this
work the best done they nailed it like
they hit the checklist and then you get
armor rolls you don't need weapon copies
anymore
thank you shout out to Destin and I Gian
world and anybody else anarchy is going
up to 10% he gets a whole five percent I
literally saw Paul testy tweet something
out saying hey this is really cool and
Dustin was like this is not the most
important thing and literally tweets
back the anarchy percentage up that was
his reply was like that is classic
that's classic yes I did that
I don't mean to laugh at his pain but it
is a photo I laugh at it I notice your
boy 75 more runs and I get a throw him
an anarchy party so concerned no he's he
just he'll ask me sometimes but uh he'll
hello if gia usually and sometimes
they'll hop in and help him and most the
time he just kind of gets it done on
Tuesday then cries a little protocol is
getting to change the wave seven chest
no longer requires a key chest can be
opened every successful wave seven
attempt each time it opens the chest
Awards one piece of armour until your
character has all of them afterwards it
is a random piece of armor so fully
changing up how that works the weapons
will still s koushin critical weapon
drops were not touched and is still
cumulative stream boss drops that stuffs
the weapons are changed if I could
comment on escalation protocol real
quick this change took way too long
way too long like the the bizarre system
to get the key charged to get the armor
was like and you only do one a week per
character yes and it was like what a
strange and I wish the said cause I'm
stretching out curse of Osiris or no war
war my I guess but I mean it's good
they're doing it finally because I think
the EP armor is one of the coolest
looking armor sets but I don't know if
people actually can go back and play EP
no I don't know if it's just match
making in there perfect you'd be great
that's our gonna be one of my favorite
if he just had magic making weapon mods
are gonna be 500 and so five thousand
glimmer don't thumbs up yeah repeatable
bounties at the gunsmith also double
thumbs up our merge the strike crucible
gambits
gunsmith weekly bounty to field
calibration
so you're not forced into anything you
don't ask me I haven't finished it the
that pounding because I did trifecta for
a while I just want to play one or two
things yeah and then we did get some
changes to a couple subclasses as well
Thunder crash had increased damage in
flight damage and flight time which
doesn't hurt anything Thunder crash
could always use a little buff
especially PvE I would say it probably
can always never hit hard enough fun
fact there is a metal tribe towards zero
points in PvP for killing those even
exist oh yeah
killing I think it's two or three people
in Thunder crash will who have flown for
five seconds minimum five seconds and
man that tribe sucks it's like waiting
in PvP with like an arc sniper and being
like here he comes
no no you have to be the one doing the
Thunder crash killing to two or three
people I think it's two people when
you're in the air no you have to be
flying for five seconds I was the lack
of distance okay and I think I think the
super I think the super only lasts like
six seconds and towards the end you
start you start falling so we so I
already have the triumph but pick thumbs
up Night Stalker where the Pathfinder
vanish in smoke at a short period after
invisibility is applied we're firing
weapons are performing other actions
will not break invisibility and then
voidwalker handheld supernova adjust a
grenade charge time so it lines up with
the animation and ethics this should
make it feel more consistent I hate that
friggin Oh about that way that's a Titan
warlock beef I totally don't use
handheld supernova ever or mean that
once I don't I don't know what that is
but you know the Titans if they would
have complained this is what they
complain about but it's cool a couple
crucible Maps rusted lands we know is
coming dead cliffs lesions gulps
retribution and solitude I think the
ones they pulled are coming back yes and
then they're removing
imperio emperor's respite and Equinox
firebase echo and Vostok there's a
couple in there that actually kind of
enjoy so respite nobody likes that guy I
don't like any of those so like it if I
could Pat the man or woman on the back
there thank you sir or madam for your
kind work
the nine map that's an l-shape oh that
going to bushes yeah yeah no that that's
fire bicycles the one on earth I think
or is that the the one with the drill
that be I think or maybe Mexico is the
one where there's the shielded tunnel in
the upper deck where the heavy ammo
sitting up at the top and point B is
below it under bushes that have sex I
just googled it I know you're talking
about now it's got the two shields at
the top with the long hallway and they
have a long like tiny hallway with the
shield like Windows the shield windows
that you can see up through education
hate that way you're right and that's
the one where B is underneath yeah no
you're right teddy Vostok is that one
was made for break-neck specifically I
think that's why it's another
breakthrough and then Vostok is the
outdoor snowing I am Branagh one that's
the iron banner beamed Saladin used to
be yeah I flip-flop on that map a lot I
like it or hate it but I'm in the middle
okay so what happened to the map that
was the big circle and it was it was
like Kabbalah themed it was like you
know it was red and it had the big
circle and um tan they took it away I
thought that was what firebase I could
you I see what you reminded me out but
oh an emperor's her spite is the other
one that's leaving and that is the one
that is like Alice one yeah that one
looks but time at plays awful yeah it is
weird for playing so two more topics
guys I know this has been a long one
thank you guys for being here this has
been a long point tonight but there are
a couple of the top
because we've been into it so uh you
guys can tell me which order you want to
talk about this ever verse and then new
level power cap let's go new level first
I think every verse is gonna be heated
topic yes I think this one might be too
but alright so powerful and pinnacle
reward caps power cap is up to 960 from
950 so plus Tim and pinnacle cap is 970
up from 960 also plus 10 watts I kind of
expected this I I didn't call it exactly
but I was like they're not gonna do like
a plus 50 again so I figured it was
gonna be like a plus 10 or plus 20 or
something so it kinda makes sense I kind
of don't like that this sets the
precedent for the the 10 pinnacle power
of the season basically being pointless
because if I don't want to grind for it
next season I'll just immediately get
that in like a week with all the
powerful that are available to me unless
they're changing the amount of powerful
is available which I don't think they
will and because of the recent change
true pinnacle drops I think this makes
it way too easy to hit it but I also
think the old way was really bad so it's
kind of that pendulum problem right
where it's like you've had it too hard
and now it's too easy but I don't know
it makes sense like hopefully the
activities don't necessarily scale that
way like a 980 nightfall on day 1 is so
it's still fine right because we're
gonna lose the artifact so all that
power governor artifact goes away but I
don't know anybody guys think it just it
messes with my old-school destiny mind
the old-school way of doing things
change but I mean I you know with teddy
the part that Teddy said is the part
that I it needles me a bit about the
artifact subtracting and then we're
coming back and we're just doing that
and it's just like
I don't know I mean I'm saying you know
I see both sides of it I shot the tasks
he shot the loan all those guys I don't
even going back and forth with this
debate on how it would happen
you know I am surprised it did because
obviously our destiny my destiny mind is
is conditioned you know we're supposed
to have a 50-point or whatever and this
is this is definitely I'm changing you
know um again the only thing I struggle
with is chess at the end of a season
artifact taking that extra power away
and you know I don't know how I feel
about it and then obviously we got to
see the pinnacle cap being that it's
just up to 970 that would lend me to
think or a guess that is they're gonna
keep that cadence with the the amount of
the minimal amount of you know pinnacles
and that is something you know II I
really struggle with especially that
I've lately converted into being a solo
player because you know outside of the
raid which there's no no raid outside of
a dungeon which is no new dungeon yeah I
mean but we'll we have to we have to see
how you can do it we have to see how
also shadow keeps pinnacles I'm assuming
I'm not gonna be pinnacle anymore I
don't know the raid in the dungeon I see
there's no way they take those away
otherwise there's how else are you gonna
get up there those are your main
pinnacles outside of iron banner I would
hope so
I would definitely hope so you know say
again they just I want to see how they
handle the distribution of pinnacle
rewards that's my biggest problem with
these news to start of this new season
into into Dorne
so I'm cautiously scared
let's gave a list yeah I don't you ready
to go chubby to be get it so for me this
one's interesting just because I've been
wondering what they're gonna do and
there was a Twitter thread that I read
not gonna say who it was if you got a
chance to read it cool if you didn't
it's gone now but basically the idea
here is we have they're trying to walk a
and balance in between - so you have
your hardcore people who grind it up to
960 and low nose Theory it was like hey
the group pinnacle grind when it was
once before it was twos and got easier
now they see that it's easier okay so
we'll make it tin again but then if you
are somebody say you have to travel for
two months and your season gets totally
scheduled you're like well I guess I'm
just gonna catch up with the powerful
and literally one week probably so what
the old pinnacle grind was that took
somebody all season this also takes like
your full season grind for like the top
players and you're sitting at 960 gears
cord you start the season at only
pinnacles helping you now one powerful
reward is gonna help you if you or 960
now not one powerful reward in the game
rate is gonna help you pray and that
that was the same issue whether it was
like only artifact 9 59 60 in like 960
was just a grind for the year at once
which was gonna be slower or same thing
now whether it's just tin you got you
spin all season knocking out these
pinnacles and you get there and as you
said it might be quicker now it probably
will be fairly faster but then it's just
like or you weights in the next season
and you have it like you know powerful
drops in a week and you're done and then
you have the pitiful grind you're like a
week behind the hardcore player who
plays for three months straight so then
does the hardcore person's time feel
valued and also all the other powerful
things in the game every single person
who does bounties in the tower your
strikes your gambit matches your
crucible matches your rotators all of
those have next to no point very quickly
don't bro I haven't done gambit in weeks
I haven't done activities that I would
normally do in weeks because it's no
incentive right there's no incentive you
that's the biggest problem I think that
it's floor I'm so glad you said it it's
flawed like the if they're gonna do this
at least cuz to me you kill off those
activities for the hardcore player so at
least you need to offer an option
similar to how they did with the
nightfall when you got your levels
either some type of incentive or with
wins score or
in said activity that was only a
powerful that at least there's an
opportunity to get a pinnacle in that
based on level of difficulty or whatever
cuz that's my problem right now destiny
the wage structure is I am NOT playing
those activities without any pinnacle
reward I'm eliminating every once I have
that camp I'm living every powerful
thing off the map which sucks because
these activities are real cool to play
I'm sorry I had to go on you got me go
no no I mean that was the point I was
getting at so I mean you have all these
activities you have bounties at every
one of the characters I'm like it's just
another role of something it's not gonna
be a good role in armor by the way cuz
most all the things you get from your
bounty turn and suck mm-hmm the heist at
rules and this is a whole that's a
debate for another day Teddy will may
bring you back if we just do an armor
2.0 podcast but because that we could go
to town on that one but yeah that's the
big issue with that was the main issue
that tassie had is like if you don't get
the 50 power level buff you take all the
powerful rewards you take all those
activities and you don't give them a
reason to play them now the other side
of what they're trying to do and this is
where they are trying to walk a line
that they probably shouldn't be doing is
you have them trying to say hey what if
somebody falls off for season eight in
season nine
wants to come back in season 10 they
don't have to go as far to catch up so
they're trying to keep the aula cart
people somewhat satiated sounds like a
nice I was like that is what that is but
it's like it's kind of the worse of both
because you devalue the pinnacle grind
cuz you'll be done with whatever you
didn't get in about a week and then you
still have 12 point 11 more weeks and
then you're back to the pinnacle again
but then if you get to like okay so this
season if we're at 964 the powerful will
have that probably the first week or two
and then I'm like how much do I care
about the pinnacle grind to go to 970 if
I know in the first week of you know
March 10th if in that first week that's
what I'm probably gonna get it
how much incentive is there for me to do
that where's my what do I get out of
that fact roll that up in the air I have
a theory
and I have no no evidence to back this
up I just I just think this is what they
were thinking when they initially
described the pinnacle rewards I think
that the old pinnacle system from 950 to
960 where you were getting one in every
slot in India every slot up was meant to
last the whole year yes I I think it was
supposed to last the whole year and then
I think somebody a bungee did not do the
math and was like cuz reddit immediately
was like there's not enough drops in a
season to do it across three characters
and that's assuming and that's assuming
you got perfect rng which let's be real
huh that's never gonna happen
like that's that's not just not gonna
happen so I think again I have nothing
to back this up other than just like my
own intuition and theory that this was
supposed to last the whole the whole
year and because of the backlash they
got to their credit they were really
quick to correct it but I think they
swung a little too far in the easier
direction and now it's I mean like you
said it just it really devalues like I'm
not even I'm 60 and that's because I
just don't even care like I'm like it
just doesn't matter and now that they
put this out it was like in and we
really blend it and do it yeah in a week
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get the last
drop I need to hit 960 and guess what I
only have to do pinnacles and you know
what I ain't doing any of those powerful
rewards because those are useless so
like that's again it goes back to this
time management thing right I'm not
gonna do the flash point because the
flash point doesn't give me anything I
need and there's no gear that comes from
that that's desirable so it's an I agree
with you like it's just this is weird
it's this weird problem and I don't have
a solution for it I think doing I think
doing the 50 power is also too much
because then you have to get to balance
all these things right like if you if
there is it by 50 the nightfall has to
go up the Nightmare hunts which if
you're still doing them for whatever
reason those that become a joke or
easier the raid now becomes really easy
or easier because you're doing more
damage to things instances they change
how level damage scaling works from 50
to 100 you're doing more now so that
there's all those are the things they
they probably considered and we're like
it's just easier if we do this ten but I
totally agree with you that it just 100%
D values your hardcore players time
which in my opinion this is 100% opinion
I think that's the audience you
like I'm you know I would consider
myself a hardcore player I'm not the
harness of hardcore players but I would
consider you guys probably hardcore
players as well but you know if you
cater to them everything just trickles
down right like yeah and people learn
people adapt people get better and it
becomes this this ever your community
thrives right mmm now there are games
and arguments cases against that then I
think where that didn't happen but
that's another topic because I think
that's gamer culture more than the game
but it's I don't know it's an
interesting problem right like like how
would you guys solve it if if you were
at Bungie and they gave you and you're
in the meeting room with two people and
you're like they're like figure out this
leveling problem go how would you guys
like my theory before was as you said
they swung too far with the twos that
the pinnacles like I mean okay multiple
things one it was a mental s the whole
year tell us that would be stage one if
you like the 959 sixty was like hey
here's this pinnacle grind it's gonna be
slow this is not too mint a pin in this
season let us know and then people have
been like okay well I'll do our best we
know we don't have enough to get it this
season we've looked at the drops oranjee
may or may not be there and the rng kind
of sucks but if it's meant to be the
whole year that would at least have
explained it mm-hmm
the other side is if the one they swung
it to twos people are getting up there
noticeably faster because you only need
four and I said this on a previous
podcast with you it was like some of the
range of want like like 0-2 to like
somewhere in that range so like maybe
you do get it too maybe you get some
that are mostly ones and you get this
other one that's two and you're like
guess and you get that little extra bump
that kind of pushes you maybe that
little nudge and then you get a bunch of
ones that kind of start filling the gaps
do you get another two and you're like
cool like that would kind of give a
little more and I know it's only one to
two but like one is too slow too is too
fast just the very chance set of two it
gives that little bit where that might
help you a little bit that's just that
was my only theory but I mean other than
that just if they wanted to keep it at
960 they should have just communicated
that and explained hey this is gonna be
a year but they're just like they didn't
say anything and people are like we
don't know what's happening and they
didn't even say this stuff in the stream
and everybody was like why did it take
or Dillon tweeting saying there will be
a level increase then it comes in this
and then we see like why did this take
this long yeah you know I think it's
it's the problem right now is to devalue
enough content and it just sucks it
really sucks to log into destiny right
now the last three weeks for me has been
the same thing it's like oh I bet it's a
week okay I'll play you know I can get
something out of that you know it as far
as like I said the other activities on
that director they need value they need
value we even discussed last last word
which is you know a rotating older raid
pinnacle thing you know I'm saying yeah
no that was good you know we need more
sources you know I'm saying it again
because ultimately it's not even just if
you know if they worried about the power
creep ultimate at the end of the day if
they're so concerned about locking it
into these three activities or
what-have-you you you're devaluing your
prod you have a great Bungie has a great
product have a great product like a
prime all that stuff and all these
different crew support these all these
things are fun things that the community
likes to do but when you just section it
off you know I have to see those
engagement numbers we know they look at
you know statistics very hard but we
have to see those engagement open you
have to see what's going on but I I
would be I know put it this way if I'm
not playing that's a problem yes
like I rarely stop playing this game
that's how much I love this game so it's
been a very casual focus for me that you
know the log in on a Tuesday see what's
going on with the reset you know I'm in
and out and I'm going but you know
ultimately got to see if that that
that's where this thing is gonna go and
I think it needs to be corrected that's
just where that's what I mean I can't
see this in my opinion as sustainable
for a healthy base player base if they
keep this cadence they have to change to
at least on the rewards that you have
you can't have sectioned off parts of
your game completely
you know devalued and uselessness that's
where I'm at yeah I'd have to imagine
that a very small number of players
hit the air hit the power cap just start
pinnacle so 9:50 in this case and so the
amount of players now that are only
chasing pinnacle is smaller than the
amount of players that are chasing
everything else but then you need other
players with you to do these pinnacle
things which is kind of your problem
kognito which is yeah you know you can't
do half these things solar most solo I
don't know again it's this weird problem
right like I don't have a solution for
it I don't know how they would tackle it
so hope maybe next season might might
they might have a better way of handling
it we still got one table left for the
next nail you know we still have to see
we know the engagement in what what
other changes are coming could figure
that but that's what I got yeah well the
patch notes on Tuesday and then can I
see about the final the new season tuam
since the season starts on Tuesday final
piece we've got is the ever restore
changes coming to some economy duplicate
purchases but I think the big one
everybody's curious about is the silver
only content and Teddy you sound like
you had an opinion so that's I mean I I
think it's smart of them to just release
what's gonna be silver only the
beginning this season because like that
one can read it was just leaking it
every three weeks and I was constantly
checking that sorry sorry for saying
that well yeah and and literally every
Tuesday soon as I get home or wake up
whatever I would I would check open up
dim go to vendors and see what I had
check boxes on for bright dust and I was
like alright cool like I don't have this
woman buy this one if there was
something for silver that I felt
warranted my money I would I would
purchase it but that's usually far in
between but then this leads me to do my
bigger issue which is the brightness
economy and I started shadow keep with
about 70,000 brightness it could have
been higher than that if I didn't spend
all of it for bad juju and just grinded
yeah like a like a normal man I think I
was taking it everybody shut up yeah did
a trophy room that was definitely
intentional on their part night oh you
don't get away
and I know adding carols like whatever
it doesn't matter you know in hindsight
I probably shouldn't have but we didn't
know what was coming at that time so but
I I think fits here someone on Twitter
shout out it's him and whoever did it
did the math and it was like the amount
of brightness that you're getting
currently and what the change is even
it's it's currently it's not even enough
to buy one item if you did everything on
every character that you could possibly
do every week it's like just shy of
enough to buy one item Wow an exotic
item I think you can buy like the
legendarium blues and stuff but an
exotic item it's like 2,000 plus or
whatever
it's not enough and with the new changes
coming you will have enough but that
includes events which is their change
right they're changing it so that events
now also award the same amount but even
then what if I don't play that event
what if I don't have time to do all
three characters like and you're telling
me you know this thing is only there for
a week and typically practice items are
always sold once just like the silver
items again this is this it's this weird
place that they kind of sit in because
the one hand I get it their company
their business first you know it's its
business first video games second they
might not see it like that but from the
outside that's that's how I perceive it
they have to make money to survive to
exist and so I get in and as long as
people keep buying stuff you know they
will keep making more
the duplicate protection thing I think
is uh is a warm welcome and and now now
that ever verse will just flat-out tell
you that you've what you have you have
whereas before certain items you could
buy twice which I thought was like super
bizarre yeah and I'm not really sure I'm
glad that they're listening to feedback
and I know they constantly say that but
uh because I kind of know some of them I
I do know that they do take this stuff
seriously so I never went some and and
they you know kind of make fun of them
for it sometimes but at the end of the
day that's what they do right like they
they listen and sometimes they don't
communicate what they're thinking and I
think that's something they could
improve on but yes my bigger issue with
a lot of this Everest stuff is actually
the Equality of the ever verse items
mmm I still don't quite understand why
Everest gets all the coolest stuff but
my in-game armor is a reskin and this
topics been beat dead go a thousand
times on Reddit and Twitter and whatever
but it's it is maddening to me that
every was I know for a fact every verse
is gonna have the best looking armor
let's let's just be real cartographer
the season is gorgeous yeah like and I'm
gonna lose my mind if there's another
rescanned armor in the game I used to I
used to not care about risk ins because
I know that just means a fashion game
for a lot of people but for me
personally I always put on whatever is
optimal I never care what I look like
that's just how I play I'm in the
minority when I say that I know people
don't think like that but whatever
whatever the optimal loadout is for the
thing I'm doing that's what I'm gonna
put on it's pretty rare that I take off
the optimal loadout so fashion for me is
out the door but when I'm looking at the
same armor over and over again like I do
something bring back faction rallies the
faction armor looked cool the fact that
iron banner is getting a reskin for the
second time something the first time
isn't the second time like come on guys
I'm not a developer I'm not gonna
pretend like I understand how long it
takes or the resources at the time but I
have to imagine that there's a pretty
body there's a pretty dedicated team of
people that's making this stuff talk
about it and for with each armor set I
know you got to make three because
there's three different characters
they're not that different
like the accents are a little you know
similar slightly different but it's more
or less the same right like it can't be
that hard right there has it has to be
some other reason or motive or something
but we'll never get that answer right
even if I ask them point blank privately
they're never gonna give me an answer so
I've just I've just come to accept that
this is it's the way it is and I'll
support them where I feel like it's
warranted and I'll criticize where I
also feel like it's warranted so I don't
what you guys think I kind of long rant
but our verse is always a very
interesting subject
the
sorry Eve Robley it's the way like that
this is the way I like I mean evils a
strong word but it that's what it is
right like it has success it has to
exist right it's just one of those
things you know that look
we know they at least they're
transparent what it's saying that hey
you know this is helping us as a studio
you know I remember one comment Luke
made he said you know because I've ever
first whatever it helped fund some other
bit of content it was very warm helped
fund outbreak crime yes
Oh whisper the worm ornaments help for
me oh yeah mission yes so when I hear
stuff like that I'm like okay you know
but on the flip side when I'm with teddy
is that it's like okay we've had it now
for a while
and I'm gonna be 1000% real with child
it's to the point where I'm more excited
to log in on Tuesday because ever versus
refresh is gonna be something exciting
to see rather than vendors in the game
like that's a problem like if I don't
care what shacks and you know the only
other major NPCs have but I'm coming
over there to see what Tess is talking
about you know and it's working but then
a pink mini Sparrow you got a bar right
I got a mic listen I I'm guilty I am the
first to admit if there is something
remotely fired in there I am putting the
money throws money at the screen oh that
was Express that was me I'm the throwing
money at the screen guy you know say I
admit it I fall victim but there has to
be a balance right and when you and when
Teddy's talking about people doing the
math of the algorithm or what it would
take to earn some of this stuff you know
say Dan coupled with the fact that not
only there's silver only content you
know I'm saying you know there has to be
a little bit of a balance in that regard
and I think right now it's skewed now
they are saying they are listening to
feedback you know saying they are saying
that they hear what we're saying in
referencing we've heard that before we
you know but at least I'm confident that
there will be some changes I'll put it
this way I was I was kind of
said after end-of-season opulence when
they got rid of the all of the ever
first bounties right because what they
still engage like that that to me was
weird cuz I'm like okay I get silver
only but you have so crippled us with
the amount of how this resources to get
right right that's like you're really
going into the other direction you know
I'm saying it's tough because you love
this studio you want them to survive you
want them to thrive right but at the
same time if everything is behind me
it's like man like this should never be
a point where ever verse is so much
dominating ly cooler than in game
rewarded armor or sets and stuff like
that like it's we're getting there now
like it is so much better to look at you
know the the the the the battle pass
armor then the raid armor that's a
problem that's a problem you know like
we we shouldn't be looking so much
better like you have to reward the the
gameplay you know saying and that's
that's the struggle so it's tough man
you know I do like the transparency that
they put this in here though you know I
want to give him credit I don't make
this complete bash France you know I'm
saying what they there's still not it's
still skewed way to watch in one
direction it's got a fix but that's my
rent with a weather the whole a
diversity where you had with this I mean
I'm kind of with teddy is like I started
the season at like 70,000 bright dust
and I've been really fickle with like
spending it at all because we do creep
up at such a slow slow pace and also
they're only putting bright dust into
the events yeah the dawning will be a
month long but it's still just an event
like the the other side of it as you
guys are saying is completely accurate
why does all of the cool armor have to
be in there not like give me like the
dungeon could have just a cool one just
the damn like give me so max give me a
suit to look like so Mac in the damn
dungeon mmm-hmm beat him like five times
start checking boxes on a Triumph earth
you know beat you know different I don't
know something in there or a ship from
the dungeon that actually looks like
it's kind of on fire because when we
used to do like raids what was the
coolest thing to get the raid ships now
you do a 989 thawing you get a reskin
trash ship I'm sorry I can let 980 ship
and I was like wow this is nothing new
wacker was talking about but yeah that's
so it's like what the Imperium
cartographer is the set this season it's
gorgeous it's got cool colors it's like
very almost royalty looking it looks
sick and like the raid actually I've
seen some people in the raid army they
do look kind of cool but it is like one
of the few there's not many places to
earn hardly anything that looks good and
it doesn't have to be everywhere and
they can have some sick looking stuff in
the store an arrogant and this is where
the issue of like hey if 50% of the
stuff that was sold for at bright dust
over the course of undying they're gonna
take that up to 80% of everything
available for brightness and done we
still can't get that much brightness
I've saved a lot just like some of you
guys have but for a new player who logs
in they're still screwed and they're
just buying it
or they're not and it's also some of the
prices on these things if they were
cheaper I would buy more of them mm-hmm
I'm looking at like the sets for armor
and I'm going your expansion is $10 and
you won $21 for a set like one set of
armor I'm going on excuse me
yeah that's how about to bring that up
actually that's it's hard to justify a
$10 item when your expansion is also $10
[Laughter]
I can and it's kind of like it's it's a
business practice and I understand they
may look at other things and that's a
piece of like what is your stuff valued
up but in the other side you have to
find that supply and demand and I don't
know what their data says they have
plenty of it maybe it's selling I'd
always definitely sell it she's moving
baby but I guess like
they creeped some of that stuff down or
what if they had done like you know
towards the end of the season hey if
you've waited this long and you haven't
bought it
hey here's like end of season sale on
some of the stuff it's 50% off
let's get them Black Friday discounts in
this Friday sale man oh they did it was
on the Bungie store yeah and I looks
awesome though you're brave
but yeah it's just the price per thing
it's like when the imperium
cartographers set is 2,100 for a set of
armor an ornament is 800 I'm like I
understand I want to pay your artists
and I respect all of them they are
amazing at what they do but in turn if
you don't put so many of them out of
reach if I was like if I spent 10 bucks
and I got like two or three things I
would more frequently spend that $10
because I feel like I was getting a
decent value for it and people will say
fortnight skins or 20 bucks old that's a
ripoff I would never pay either it's
like I it's just I don't know just bring
some of the prices down make the bright
desk come more frequently like it's 200
for the weekly and 10 per repeatable
bounty the only person who got to enjoy
that one is bagel for Kerry who has like
a more repeatable bounties than anybody
else he's the only one who's bright does
the season has gone up everybody else
everybody else is bright dust has been
doing doing fast and hard and you should
have those players who get like level
250 let him buy one let him buy one or
two exotics there's enough stuff in
there that you're still gonna taunt us
with money and be like hey I still got
all this cool stuff I know you want it
but at least if I earn one or two things
I can buy like that one extra thing the
kid who can't ask his parent for a cart
for a credit card but can play many
hours cuz for some reason his parents
don't care how much he plays this is
just a weird hypothetical yeah it's fine
just go play your game you're fine you
just raise yourself um but in the end
it's like at least they might have a
chance hey if I work really hard play a
lot do these bounties but I can buy that
one thing by the end of the year you're
making it so hard that you can't even
do that and I think that's as you said
it's like one exotic unattainable within
a season that's too far like you need to
either bounce the prices or give us more
bright dust because that's I think the
part however much is out there for 50%
or 80% not everything's gonna be
available that's fine the bright dust
economy I think is the harder issue that
needs looked at at this point you must
be paid heywhat now just a change has
got to be made man so yeah just for
everybody's heads up if you made it this
far in the podcast then cool cuz you
guys are hardcore and rock stars so you
guys are amazing actually so the big
thing at this point is if you haven't
done anything for the season you have
about four days to do it and then it's
all go away so check the page see what
triumphs and titles and activities you
may need to do in case you're trying to
finish things up that would be something
you might want to check on quickly and
other than that that is kind of where
they wrapped up the tois and I think
that's probably plenty for us this week
because we are coming up on like three
hours oh yeah so we have we have abused
this man's time but Teddy all right been
amazing to make it through this one
thank you all for hanging out this long
as well you guys have been great
we're gonna wrap it up but don't run off
I do want to send you guys over to
another twitch channel so we can raid
somebody so first thing before we go
Teddy tell them what you got going on if
they can find you in a we're just find
you on Twitter anything like that let
them know what you got going what are
you working on what are you looking
forward to what you got going in the
future
yeah so I'm not a streamer I actually
kind of live mostly a private life so
I'm a little more secluded but you can
find me on Twitter at a teasing Teddy it
is P EA te ASI and GT EDD Y all one word
I'm pretty good about responding to
things or anything that pops up I'm
mostly just trolling people with memes
and gifts like I said on stream or
anything I mostly play destiny you know
go to work at a school do all that all
that fun stuff and I think you guys for
having me this was a this is a blast
this is super fun
thank you brother gotta bring you back
to man yeah love the takes love
everything brought fantastic kognito
what about you sir again thanks to Teddy
for coming through man awesome guy got a
chance to meet a bad Guardian kind and
he first of all warlock main and
controller game I got Audion brothers I
got a clip that intro you made man that
was like I don't think my wedding will
be that good just researching people in
the community and yours is a cool story
obviously got a chance to see you at
when we at the fireteam chat what was it
he we were both sitting there during the
panel yeah we were front row for the
little panel yeah so we got to see our
boys it's just really cool to see you
know to put that their faces to the
names and the Twitter accounts and stuff
like that so I always loved that time of
experience and hopefully you're a
guardian con gcx excuse me actually my
first year I been wanting to go for a
long time but the stars kind of did in a
line and I'll make the story a little
short but they some stuff happened and
then stuff didn't happen we ended up I
ended up going with with Dustin and CJ
and that was that was a blast and I
can't imagine not going to that so floor
does not so great sorry to anyone that
lives in Florida yeah but regarding con
gcx yeah I'm super super pumped for that
so I'll see you guys there absolute
YouTube the Lord's will be returning to
the realm this Sunday again 11 a.m.
Eastern we will have our switch content
creators the flannel Fox very cool
youtuber we will be talking that will
also do some gamer game Awards
nomination we have slow fun series and
call crown your Lord so everyone's gonna
do their predictions if they got the
good game was gonna win in which
category if that ratings gonna sweep
this thing you know they all that good
stuff so it's your blood that's training
control would be mine so I'm just
guessing I haven't played either
actually so there will be a very highly
contested tally up of the votes and then
what we do the following week is we
crown the winner based on who guessed it
correct so yeah check us out on that I
was the Iowa podcast and of course Lords
of gaming dotnet really appreciate all
the support you guys have been giving us
the team was really important some great
articles out there we got a couple of
Destiny articles right now and we had
Josh reading one on the show he put up
in reference to the reveal and the fact
that the Lords predicted it we were the
foot of the first predict to the whole
whole Cyrus and possibly State 14 from
way back so I should check that out so
you support the guys but yeah that's
what I got man I'm going to be watching
something on one monitor and spending a
whole lot of time in vex offensive on
the other undying literally it's all vex
offensive that's basically left so
that's what that's what remains for me
if I make it through you guys will see
that title sitting underneath there if
my sanity can survive it I've got the
house to myself this weekend so it's
just me and the dogs and we'll see what
happens so that's the goal but you guys
can find me on twitch TV /e montes
youtube ebon tests if you find the
cheetah and my name you've probably
tripped into the right place so thank
you guys as always for the support
clement trying to see if i can be an
official gcx content creator by the time
it comes around i got about 65 hundred
subs to go so we're trying so 50k is
apparently that mark and you guys have
been really supportive so I can't thank
you although it's an idea let's get him
there come on so thank you all very much
and again as always if you guys check
the comments you ever listen on on audio
and you made it to the end you guys are
all awesome right now if you guys are on
Twitch I'm gonna send you guys over to
miss noodle she's playing destiny she
was really cool very nice
so go say hi to her for us but for all
of us here at Eddy what we try to do
you'll probably recognize this from
fireteam chat but as the title of the
podcast is the last word we literally
ended with those specific words so I'm
gonna wrap up the episode number in the
noin essay and it has been we all try
and coordinate the last word together
but discord always screws this up just
be early what he says yeah I got it
don't wait on me you guys say it
I'll chime in so alright so it has been
episode 83 December 6 our awesome guests
teasing Sethi find them on Twitter
kognito it's been great thank you guys
very much and it has been the last word